fillon recueille bonjour on est en
direct ce vendredi après-midi pour vous
faire suivre un événement très attendu
pour le monde du football c'est le
tirage au sort de la coupe du monde avec
sébastien ferra bonjour sébastien
bonjour rassemblera tous on va suivre
bien sûr ce tirage au sort qui va se
dérouler alors la cérémonie va pas
tarder à commencer ça risque d'être un
peu long comme ça on aura le temps de
discuter n'hésitez pas pendant cela il
va poser toutes vos questions je vois
que vous êtes déjà très nombreuses voix
rta caunes en scène michael athéna et
qui sont là voilà vous n'hésitez pas
bien sûr à poser vos questions va
essayer d'y répondre au mieux possible
sébastien ceux déjà on peut peut-être
expliquer ce tirage au sort comment il
va se dérouler dans les grandes lignes
ouais alors comment il va se dérouler
bas on a comme tout le monde le sait on
à 32 équipes enfin 29 en réalité parce
qu'on a là encore 3 dont on ne connaît
pas l'identité comme il va se dérouler
chaque équipe va être et est déjà
répartie dans un chapeau donc chaque
équipe va être chacun son tour envoyé
dans un groupe on va commencer par le
chapeau 1 donc les têtes de série les
principales équipes dont l'équipe de
france évidemment et on va les répartir
chacune leur tour dans cinq ans ensuite
effectivement donc chapeau un jabot deux
chapeaux 3 chapeau 4 mais ce serait
beaucoup trop simple si on prenait juste
des équipes et colas était il avait lieu
petite subtilité ou avec quelques
subtilités alors au niveau des des
confédérations plus que les continents
c'est à dire que deux équipes d'une même
confédération ne peuvent pas être dans
le même groupe à l'exception de l'europe
parce que si on fait le compte c'est
très simple on a huit groupes et je
crois qu'on a douze nations européennes
donc forcément il y aura au moins deux
nations européennes dans un même groupe
ça c'est obligatoire mais par exemple on
pourra pas avoir de nations africaines
dans un même groupe de nations sud
américaines dans un même groupe ça ce
sera impossible donc forcément ça va un
petit peu dicté le tirage au sort on
rappelle bien sûr que l'équipe de france
est championne du monde en titre et aura
du coup on va dire un peu une cible sur
le dos lors de lors de ce mondial ce
sera un pôle l'équipe à battre ouais
l'équipe à abattre est l'équipe à éviter
forcément parce que tout à l'heure on va
parler des meilleurs tirages ou des pire
tirage pour l'équipe de france mais pour
la plupart des pays je pense que dans le
pire tirage il ya l'équipe de france
effectivement alors on va montrer un peu
les différents chapeaux avec sur quoi on
pourrait on pouvoir arriver ces
différents tirages donc le japon à la
france on va jouer contre une équipe du
chapeau 2 une équipe chapeau 3 une
équipe du chapeau 4 qu'est-ce qui serait
on va peut-être commencer par aller le
meilleur tirage qu'est ce qui serait le
meilleur tirage quelle est l'équipe à
récupérer dans le chapeau 2 le meilleur
tirage évidemment c'est toujours
relative parce que ça reste sur le
papier quand ils arrivèrent aucun match
facile dans une coupe du monde ça
ressemblait à tous maintenant si on doit
désigner un meilleur tirage allez on a
envie de dire que les états unis c'est
peut-être l'équipe de moindre calibre en
tout cas dans ce chapeau parce que c'est
une équipe jeune assez inexpérimentée
qu'elle beaucoup de mal dans son dans
son groupe de qualification qui ça s'est
joué d'ailleurs au au dernier match où
ils ont perdu contre le costa rica mais
il fallait qu'ils perdent je crois 5 ou
6 0 pour se retrouver
dehors ils ont perdu que 2 0 entre
guillemets donc qui s'en sont sortis
maintenant c'est pas l'équipe la plus
effrayante du tout de chapeau 2 je pense
alors je alors juste avant on à une
question sur les solutions sur les dates
des coupes du monde de d'athéna qui ne
demande qu'à voir la coupe du monde elle
aura lieu du 21 au 18 décembre 21
novembre au 18 décembre une date assez
inhabituelle puisque on ne peut pas
jouer aux quatre ans pourrait jouer au
football en fête l'été comme c'est
normalement le cas pour une coupe du
monde oui l'été ça va être très
compliqué parce que les conditions
météorologiques ne seront pas du tout
propice à apa à jouer au football dans
de bonnes conditions en raison surtout
de la chaleur donc on va se retrouver à
jouer l'été ça sera pas non plus des
conditions idéales et on a des stades
climatisés
ces conditions quand même assez assez
étrange assez particulière et puis
forcément bas pour nous en tout cas en
france ça me fait un petit peu bizarre
de rentrer chez nous lorsqu'il fera 5
degrés qui va neiger dehors pour
regarder la coupe du monde ça va changer
des habitudes
et des dalton demandent à quelle heure
le tirage le tirage va avoir lieu là le
l'annoncent c'était que ça commence la
cérémonie commence à 18h bien sûr on ne
vous la diffuse pas puisque nous n'avons
pas les droits mais par contre on répond
à toutes vos questions et on vieillit on
vit ensemble ce tirage donc vous
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions une
fois de plus beaucoup beaucoup de gens
dans les commentaires des ja qui parle
de l'algérie et de l'italie qui ne
seront bien évidemment pas à la coupe du
monde je pense que ça va durer à peu
près un moment cette blague dans les
commentaires vous pouvez continuer si
vous voulez mais voilà donc on parlait
justement de ces de ses chapeaux de c2c
de ce tirage facile tirage facile le
tirage le moins difficile au peut être
qu'on peut dire plutôt donc les états
unis a priori dans le chapeau 2 dans le
chapeau 3 qui serait l'équipe a récupéré
dans le chapeau 3 déjà ça se resserre
peut-être un petit peu j'ai tendance à
penser que la tunisie mais quand même
une équipe assez abordable en tout cas
sur ce qu'elle a pu montrer à la can ou
dans ses matches en éliminatoires c'est
pas une équipe qui a fait non plus forte
impression c'est pas c'est pas du tout
une équipe à craindre je pense qu'à des
sélections un petit peu plus
intimidantes comme comme le sénégal pour
le coup qui est champion d'afrique
ben oui la tunisie la pologne aussi qui
est quand même assez assez faible
finalement certain robert lewandowski
malheureusement l'équipe se résume pas à
lui et on a pu voir sur les sur les
barrages notamment de discuter en off
que sur les barrages n'ont pas fait
forte impression du tout voilà c'est
peut-être les équipes qui sortent un peu
du lot dans le mauvais sens dans le
chapeau 3 et peut-être l'ignorant aussi
ce n'est pas vraiment habitué à
performer en cours effectivement l'iran
qui est plutôt habitué aux dernières
places deux groupes est dans le chapeau
4 on a alors on a cameroun canada
équateur arabi 2,8 ghana pour les
équipes connues et ensuite eh bien il y
a trois autres
équipes qui vont qui vont arriver mais
on n'est pas on ne sait pas encore qui
va va y être ouais on ne sait pas parce
qu'il ya encore des matches à jouer en
moins de gens alors dans le cadre du
barrage européen c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que il ya le cadre de
l'ukraine suite à l'invasion de la
russie qui n'a pas pu jouer son barrage
comme prévu donc le match a été reporté
en juin donc forcément ça retarde un peu
l'échéance par contre ce qui était prévu
c'était que les barrages
intercontinentaux comme on les appelle
se joue en juin donc ça va concerner des
équipes de différentes confédérations
donc ça va jouer en juin donc
effectivement il ya ces équipes qu'on on
connaîtra pas encore l'identité il
faudra attendre encore deux trois mois
avant de savoir qui seront ses équipes
qui iront à la coupe du monde et
malheureusement ils se font un petit peu
à voir en terme de chapeau pour
certaines au niveau du classement fifa
je pense au pays de galles qui s'ils
étaient déjà qualifiés aurait été dans
le chapeau 2 là qui se retrouve du coup
d'office pour ne pas trop faux c'est le
tirage dans le chapeau 4 dans le cas où
le pays de galles se qualifie ce sera
peut-être un petit peu les les perdants
de l'histoire effectivement alors on
rappelle que laisser ces équipes-là ses
chapeaux sont fait via le classement
fifa et le pays de galles ou l'ukraine
par exemple aurait pu être dans le
chapeau 2 grâce à l'heure alors bon
résultat et se retrouver devant des pays
comme la tunisie ou la corée du sud par
exemple ouais c'est aussi une mauvaise
nouvelle en fait pour les autres équipes
parce que est ce que le pays de galles
ou ou l'ukraine sont vraiment des
équipes du chapeau 4 ça on peut se
permettre d'en douter donc forcément ça
va être peut-être l'équipe en tout cas
les équipes plutôt vraiment à éviter je
pense d'anciens on ag b qui me demandent
vous ne pensez pas que le tirage des
billets et parce qu'on ne connaît pas
encore les trois derniers pays alors oui
il est biaisé on peut dire qu'il est
biaisé d'une partie mais d'un côté
dallas plus n'a plus le choix au bout
d'un mois ah oui elle n'a plus le choix
alors après l'on connaît pas tous les
détails le long terme de logistique mais
on peut douter que c'est un petit peu
compliqué de faire le tirage au sort au
dernier moment pour plein de raisons
d'organisation maintenant il ya pour
l'otan pour les barrages
intercontinentaux on pourra en discuter
on pourrait se demander comment ça se
fait que ça ne soit pas déjà décidé
autant dans le cas de l'ukraine il ya
vraiment un événement exceptionnel qui a
fait qu'ils ont été obligés de tout
décalé parce qu'il voulait absolument
pas jouer le match maintenant donc il
n'y a pas d'autre solution donc pas non
plus vraiment repoussé le tirage au sort
je pense que c'était aussi quelque chose
de très compliqué à mettre en place donc
voilà il faudra malheureusement en irak
dans les commentaires on nous parle
encore du match algérie cameroun où on
nous dit que le match de ce soir sera à
devrait être à rejouer c'est que c'est
quand même assez peu probable qu'une
chose pareille arrive oui c'est peu
probable je sais pas s'il ya déjà eu des
antécédents à ce niveau là mais aussi
c'est ce qu'a demandé je crois la
fédération algérienne qu'elle a fait la
demande officielle
c'est quand même très probable qu'un tel
match soit rejoué plusieurs jours plus
tard ce soit délibéré avec autant de
retard en plus
malheureusement je pense qu'il faudra se
faire à l'idée que l'algérie ne sera pas
la coupe du monde voilà donc pendant ce
temps là la cérémonie se poursuit ça n'a
pas encore débuté bien évidemment le
tirage au sort on commença cérémonie 18
heures le tir le sort a lieu un peu plus
tard on a parlé alors dans le dans le
chapeau 4 du coup sûr les sur les cinq
équipes connues qu'elles seraient
l'équipe a priori la plus la plus
abordable
la plus abordable sur les cinq équipes
connues on pourrait penser aller que
l'arabie saoudite c'est quand même un
niveau relativement faible faible
évidemment on sent ensemble parce que ça
reste la coupe du monde mais ça reste
quand même largement abordable c'est pas
du tout une équipe qui performent coupe
du monde qui pose rarement des soucis à
des à des grosses nations ce serait
relativement abordable pour l'équipe de
france effectivement sachant qu
effectivement l'iran et la république
par rien ne pourrait pas se retrouver
dans la même poule d'ailleurs on avait
une question tout à l'heure
je sais plus de qui était cette question
c'était de hubert cuisant le qatar et
l'arabie saoudite peuvent-ils se
rencontrer avant la finale un peu comme
la russie et l'ukraine qui ne pouvaient
ils ne le peuvent pas en champion's
league par exemple pour des raisons
forcément politique alors le problème le
problème ne devrait pas trop temps se
pose et vu qu'il est peu probable déjà
le qatar et l'arabie saoudite venant de
la même fédération fédération il ne va
pas jouer l'un contre l'autre pour 1 go
il faudrait que la sorte premier lot
c'est l'autre sorte deuxième c'est
improbable oui c'est très improbable
déjà si une de ces deux équipes se
qualifier en huitièmes de finale ça
serait un véritable exploit pour
n'importe laquelle de ces deux là
ensuite pour qu'elles se rencontrent il
faudrait vraiment un scénario incroyable
maintenant si ça arrive là pour coup la
fifa ne pourra rien faire le match aura
lieu on peut pas annuler un match pareil
on peut par modifier le tirage au sort
ça ça devrait avoir lieu à temps dans un
contexte de coupe du monde c'est quand
même assez assez assez safe j'ai envie
de dire il n'y a pas grand chose à
craindre je pense si ça arrive ça doit
arriver mais c'est extrêmement
improbable alors que la la la la
cérémonie est en train de se poursuivre
on a alors david obey qui nous parle de
le dollar est justement la russie qui
devait participer aux barrages et qui a
été exclu de la compétition suite à ce
qui s'est passé à la l'invasion de
l'ukraine et la pologne a été a été est
passé directement dans son barrage la
russie est éliminé directement à cause
de ça oui voilà la russie
malheureusement les joueurs russes en
tout cas puni par le par le contexte
politique c'est un petit peu un petit
peu malheureux évidemment pour pour les
joueurs et pour le football en russie
maintenant la fifa après une décision
qui paraît quand même assez assez
logique en tout cas qu'après une
décision forte qui c'est qui a tranché
dans le vif
il fallait le faire en tout cas il
fallait au moins réagir et choisir faire
un choix dans dans et ce que la russie a
le droit ou n'a pas le droit d'être là
la fifa a tranché donc effectivement on
ne verra pas la russie qui était
pourtant organisatrice il ya quatre ans
donc on a parlé des débits a plutôt à
jouer on va dire dans l'épreuve pour
avoir donc pour pourvoir voilà pour
pouvoir arriver on peut parler
maintenant des équipes à éviter dans le
chapeau 2 clairement pour la france
c'est l'allemagne qui va poser problème
ou l allemagne on pourrait peut-être
mettre les pays bas un peu hauteur moi
j'ai envie quand même de mettre
l'allemagne un petit peu au dessus
oui l'allemagne parce que toute façon
toutes les coupes du monde tout le monde
a envie un peu de les éviter encore
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une nation
très forte même si à l'euro ça s'était
bien passé pour les bleus puisqu'il y
avait sept victoires en phase de poule
où l'équipe de france avait vraiment été
largement à la hauteur et l'allemagne un
petit peu moins maintenant l'allemagne
c'est quand même pas une équipe facile
facile à jouer surtout en phase de
poules certes y'a luce cet accident la
dernière forme qui ne sont pas sortis
pour le coup de la phase de poules qui
n'avait quasiment jamais mais si une
équipe est encore beaucoup grand joueur
qui a énormément d'expérience qui trompe
quand même plutôt pas mal dans sa phase
éliminatoire oui c'est une équipe qui
vaut mieux éviter un petit peu comme les
pays-bas finalement qu'à peut-être moins
de vécu moins d'expérience moins de
repères finalement mais oui les pays-bas
l'allemagne ça reste les équipes élite
et surtout l'amanite cdc des équipes un
peu en reconstruction on peut le dire
oui un petit peu en reconstruction en
tout cas elle n'arrive pas avec le
statut de l'équipe de france dès lors
très peu d'équipés arrivent avec le
statut de l'équipe de france pourra
peut-être parlé un petit peu après deux
des trois cadres favori qui se dégage en
général de la compétition mais
effectivement pour l'équipe de france
même s'il ya ces fameux meilleur et pire
tirage pour pour une équipe comme les
bleus franchement ya pas vraiment de
pire charge on aime les arrêts qui nous
dit on prie pour avoir un groupe simple
est-ce que c'est forcément une bonne
chose c'est un grand débat c'est est ce
que c'est une bonne chose d'avoir un
groupe compliqué où un groupe simple
pour démarrer une compétition comme ça
je pense que ça dépend juste après de
commandes l'équipe l'équipe concernée
aborde à bord de ces rencontres je pense
pas qu'il y ait de recette miracle il ya
des équipes qui ont ils des groupes
simple et qui s'en sont très bien sortis
qui sont parfois aller au bout c'est un
peu le cas des bleus d'ailleurs en 2018
qui avait un groupe assez abordable
maintenant il ya aussi des équipes qui
avaient des groupes plus compliqué et
qui ont su être tout de suite à la
hauteur et qui sont allés au bout donc
ya pas de recette miracle j'ai quand
même envie de penser que c'est mieux
d'avoir un groupe relativement abordable
d'avoir le temps de monter en puissance
par contre il faut surtout pas que pour
l'équipe concernée s'affale moment de se
reposer de se relâche deux manqué son
entrée en compétition sinon ça peut
coûter très cher on a saisi l ouïe lee
qui nous demandent à quelle heure a lieu
le tirage de la cérémonie a débuté
depuis 18 heures mais une cérémonie de
2,2
quant à un tirage de coupe du monde on
sait le début la cérémonie mais on ne
sait pas à quelle heure va vraiment
avoir lieu le tirage au sort or lui-même
oui voilà là ça commence mais on sait
pas on sait pas du tout où ce qui va se
passer toutes les personnes qui vont
arriver sur l'estrade qui vont dire
bonjour qui vont obtenir un joli
discours peut-être des prix qui vont
être remis tout ça là franchement c'est
un peu le moment on va pas se mentir
ennuyeux où on a juste envie franchement
que ça commence de connaître un petit
peu les équipes de savoir qui sera dans
quel groupe au moins pour le chapeau 1
même si le chapeau 1 ça a commencé en
douceur forcément parce que chaque
équipe sera chacun son tour dans un
groupe ii coup d'oeil on ne saura pas
qui affronte ici mais au moins ça
donnera déjà une idée ça tu aura même
une idée par rapport aux huitièmes de
finale puisque on sera déjà après qui
peut affronter qui potentiellement 8e
effectivement on vous décrypte aura tout
ça alors que idris elba qui vient
d'arriver sur la sur la scène mais qui
est en train de faire un petit discours
d'avant pour avancer vous pensez que le
brésil va montrer quelque chose
l'adhésion de quai k le brésil est il
devenu redevenu on peut le dire quelque
part une grande nation du football c'est
vrai que l'on a vu que le brésil était
redevenu la première nation au
classement fifa alors le classement fifa
je pense pas qu'ils fassent gage de paix
en tout cas c'est pas le classement qui
disent il vraiment de quelle est la
meilleure équipe du monde qu'elle est la
moins bonne ça se résume pas du tout à
ça je pense que les premières depuis un
moment exactement la belgique est
preneur depuis un moment elle n'a pas
gagné grand chose pourtant
donc il faut pas trop non plus fier à ça
maintenant le brésil argentine ils sont
difficiles forcément à jauger parce que
son équipe d'amérique du sud qui ont une
concurrence moindre par rapport aux
nations européennes
en tout cas les aux équipes que sont
habitués à affronter l'équipe de france
la belgique le portugal l'espagne
l'allemagne
on l'a vu notamment l'euro et on l'a vu
à la copa america le niveau n'est pas
vraiment le même le brésil argentine ont
survolé leur groupe c'est évidemment
donation en dehors des équipes
européennes qu'il faut éviter c'est les
deux nations qui trône un petit peu au
dessus maintenant c'est aussi deux
nations qui ont un leader chacune qui
implantent dans avec neymar pour le
brésil messi pour l'argentine alors il
ya encore du temps avant la coupe du
monde et on en parlera tout à l'heure
c'est pas c'est pendant trois mois c'est
que dans six mois donc il ya encore du
temps pour les équipes pour se
construire pour certains joueurs pour se
mettre un petit peu en forme
mais je pense qu'il ya trois quatre
nations européennes qui sont au dessus
du brésil et l'argentine si on s'arrête
à aujourd'hui alors la matiz qui nous
demande c'est quoi et chapeau donc les
chapeaux c'est alors on va peut-être
montré ce visuel qui était à l'écran je
remercie riad d'ailleurs qui à la
réalisation de ce live donc les chapeaux
à chaque on va avoir une équipe déjà
points contre une équipe chapeau 2 une
équipe javaux tronic japon 4 pour
trouver quel est le groupe enfin la pl
poule c pour la spao pour comment va se
dérouler la poule avec bien évidemment
beaucoup de petits mais on a expliqué
déjà les petits problèmes les plus de
facilités pour pour tous pour trouver
alors je vois beaucoup beaucoup de
questions en même temps donc c'est pour
ça que genre j'ai bafouillé un peu les
pronos pour le groupe de la france va
c'est un peu compliqué de vous donner
des bouts de bouder des pros noble des
dépôts des pronos puisque ça n'a pas
encore débuté la croatie aura du mal et
effectivement la croatie chapeau 2 va
devoir jouer contre un gros alors qu'ils
étaient finalistes de la dernière coupe
du monde oui voilà alors clairement
clairement cravacher
c'est une nation on va pas dire qu'elle
est absolument pas là par hasard au
mondial 2018 elle avait largement mérité
sa place elle a été impressionnante
maintenant est ce que c'est une nation
qui peut représenter un frein à une
finale c'est pas une nation qu'à
l'habitude de ça d'ailleurs c'est ça
reste une très belle équipe qui sort de
très bons joueurs toujours un mec a
quand même une génération un petit peu
glissante incarné par par luka modric
qui est quand même on le sent plus plus
dense a dans sa première jeunesse ça
reste évidemment une équipe pas vraiment
à prendre au sérieux avec quelques gros
joueurs je pense notamment de marcelo
bros the beach qui chaque semaine
impressionné avec l'inter milan qui
prend vraiment un leadership
impressionnant dans avec l'inter et ça
se ressent aussi forcément en équipe de
croatie maintenant oui c'est une équipe
qui va un petit peu cravacher
franchement on attend pas vraiment en
finale de coupe du monde 6e demain on
doit faire des pronostics je pense qu'on
la met très difficilement dans le
dernier carré bleu alors y'en as tornade
du bunker intéressant c est que la
france peut refaire comme en 2002
c'est-à-dire au tenant du titre et se
faire sortir dès le premier tour
évidemment on peut jamais jurer de rien
mais si aujourd'hui quelqu'un arrive à
assurer et à argumenter sur le fait que
l'équipe de france sortir en phase de
poules je vois pas comment c'est
possible en tout cas sûre même sur
l'euro qu'on l'a vu certes on pouvait
rester un petit peu sur notre faim avec
cette émulation assez pénible face à la
suisse est encore l'équipe de france
menée en fin de match et pas dire que
c'était une faute professionnelle de
finalement de perdre ce match mais dans
beaucoup de scénarios si on rejoue ce
match dix fois je pense pas que la
france le père dix fois et sur les
depuis l'équipe de france était comme je
trouve très rassurante en tout cas dans
le jeu il ya vraiment des certitudes des
garanties surtout des joueurs de classe
mondiale qui s'affirme parfaitement ça
se résume pas à qui la map et qu'il ya
m'appelle ville amants dont on parle
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas de
meilleur joueur du monde en ce moment la
question allait largement légitime et en
fait on peut se poser la question
quasiment à tous les postes est ce que
la france n'a pas le meilleur milieu de
terrain du monde ce que la france n'a
pas potentiellement la meilleure ligne
défensive du monde une défensive après
on s'entend parce que l'équipe de france
maintenant je mens 3 5 2
puisqu'on parle des 3 2 derrière des
cinq de derrière entre guillemets et
puis en plus sur ce 3 5 2 autant c'était
compliqué à l'euro autant depuis
énormément de l'assurance on voit que
l'équipe de france a énormément
progressé 10 les gens il est très
content et c'est rare qu'on voit
exprimer autant sa joie comme on l'a vu
après après l'afrique du sud l'équipe de
france qui sont en phase de poules
franchement ça paraît absolument
impossible effectivement c'est bien on a
une question d'une internaute alors que
j'ai perdu son pseudo avis et charles
parnet je pense qu'il peut être et
canadiennes ne me reste que le canada
peut réussir à arriver jusqu'en jusqu'en
huitièmes de finale les sortir d'un
groupe c'est toujours possible après
c'est palisson pas ils seront pas
favoris de leur groupe à priori non ils
seront pas là ils seront pas favoris
même s'ils ont ils ont dominé leur
l'encontre des qualifications ils ont
été la première équipe de leur
confédération à se qualifier
c'est une équipe assez jeune mais assez
fougueuse incarnée notamment par
jonathan david convois convoi à lille
c'est plutôt une équipe à éviter dans ce
chapeau 4 après c'est leur problème ils
sont dans le chapeau 4 donc forcément
ils vont avoir un groupe un petit peu
relevé ils vont pas évité les plus
grosses nations donc ça va être
difficile un peu pour pour sortir du
groupe mais c'est une équipe qui a tout
à fait les arguments pour être un petit
peu la surprise de cette coupe du monde
est ce que là on a une autre question
alors que gianni infantino est en train
d'arriver sur scène le boss de la de la
fifa y ait un petit discours bien sûr on
roule on nous a expliqué qu' on ne le
diffuserait pas
alors que pourtant merci au modérateur
qui explique que le match de l'algérie
ne sera pas pas pris part aux jouets
changeons de sujet s'il vous plaît merci
je rajoute une couche si vous voulez
effectivement ce serait ce serait pas
mal est ce que la france est favorite de
cette coupe du monde où elle est l'une
des favorites ont on avait fait ça avec
des champions il ya des équipes qui
s'étaient fait de toi un favori mais il
ya des équipes qui se détachent et
clairement la france en fait partie
ouais la france en fait partie et après
pour la ligue des champions a
effectivement ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on allait parler des favoris
lors du tirage au sort de la phase de
poules et qu'on en a l'air parler plus
tard au moment des huitièmes de finale
et on sait très bien je pense que si on
regardait les deux lèvres qu'on avait
fait je pense qu'on y est pas la même
chose d'une même équipe à ces deux
périodes différentes de l'année parce
que beaucoup de choses peuvent changer
hélas la coupe du monde c'est pas encore
une fois c'est pendant trois mois c'est
dans six mois il peut se passer beaucoup
de choses l'équipe de france va jouer au
moins six ou sept matches d'ici là donc
on verra comment ça va se passer au sein
du groupe sia pas d'accroc ci encore des
matches références et on verra aussi
pour les autres nations maintenant oui
la france fait clairement partie du de
ses équipes cinq étoiles la france fait
partie des favoris de la coupe du monde
et s'il ya une équipe une seule équipe
qui devait être favorite de cette coupe
du monde ça serait clairement la france
on l'a dit tout à l'heure la france a
une cible dans le dos
oui c'est vraiment parmi les premières
favorites je pense avec les on peut
ajouter la belgique ils ont un peu du
mal à confirmer à chaque fois c est une
nation très fort très solide très rôdée
l'allemagne on a obligé de son métier
ce qu'on peut ajouter l'angleterre moi
je pense pas forcément convaincu je
pense qu'ils ont profité comme d'un
scénario en relativement favorable à
l'euro maintenant ça leur a peut-être
servi de leçon aussi ils ont peut-être
réussi à emmagasiner ça pour revenir
plus fort voilà je pense que france
belgique angleterre l'espagne spain on
sait aussi à l'espagne pascal euros ils
ont été très impressionnants il pas
encore assez jeune qui cherche encore
quelques joueurs clés à certains postes
et quelques joueurs cadres dans son
groupe qui doit encore un petit peu ce
se construire se muscler j'irai mais oui
france belgique angleterre espagne et
peut-être l'allemagne peut-être dans ce
dans ses équipes cinq étoiles alors
qu'il ya beaucoup de commentaires sur le
sur le sénégal le sénégal qui est dans
le chapeau 3 et qui fait partie des
équipes qu'il faudrait pour le boom pour
éviter vraiment c'est un peu la plus
grosse équipe du chapeau 3 le sénégal
oui c'est sûrement la plus grosse équipe
de chapeau 3 après c'est relatif
évidemment et on peut un petit peu
discuter évidemment les équipes
asiatiques c'est pas forcément les
équipes qu'on connaît le mieux mais
signalons à la halle à cannes donc
champion en titre maintenant de la can
même sûr c'est sur ces derniers matchs
c'est peut-être l'équipe qui est le plus
sûr de sa force qui a le plus de
confiance oui c'est globalement une
équipe à éviter avec un leader
évidemment technique sadio man et ses
multiples a vraiment beaucoup de
ressources ça a tout franchement je
pense du match piège pour n'importe quel
accouchement alors on nous demande
beaucoup quand commence vraiment ce
tirage au sort cet agent sort commence
dans quelques minutes c'est une
cérémonie ça prend du temps on n'a pas
les droits exact mais dès que ça
commence promis on vous le fait vivre en
direct sans souci j'avais une question
sur parce qu'on parlait des équipes du
groupe à et on n'a pas mentionné le
portugal nous fait remarquer à
l'internaute le portugal est ce que
c'est encore un grand favori de cette
compétition est-ce qu'on peut la mettre
est-ce qu'on peut mettre cette équipe du
portugal dans les équipes cinq étoiles
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de la
mettre dans cette catégorie parce que il
ya eu l'euro où ça a été un petit peu
couci couça girel c'était il y avait un
petit peu de bien et beau coup de moins
bien et surtout dans les éliminatoires
c'était compliqué surtout sur la fin ou
au portugal a vraiment craqué notamment
du lors du match contre la serbie qui
l'a envoyé en barrage et sur les
barrages contre la turquie et la
macédoine du nord poursuit elle n'a pas
fait une grosse impression
on a vu beaucoup de fébrilité on a vu
qu'il ya un manque de 40 il manque
d'assurance dans cette équipe qui a
pourtant sur le papier une équipe
absolument exceptionnelle je me souviens
qu'à l'euro
kankankan voyait l'équipe du portugal
surtout l'attaquent on se disait on
n'arrêtait pas de dire tout le monde
nous envient la tête de l'équipe de
france une dizaine en fait le portugal
n'a peut-être pas grand-chose à envier
justement la france est-ce que c'est pas
eu la meilleure attaque du monde et en
terme de groupe et d'effectifs on peut
se poser la question mais il arrive
absolument pas capitalisé capital à
capitaliser là dessus
donc c'est un petit peu c'est un petit
peu leurs défauts ils ont paru si
vraiment à se renouveler depuis depuis
l'euro 2016 ils ont un petit peu russie
entre 2018 2019 mais depuis ça a été
plus compliqué c'est difficile de les
mettre dans les dents les équipes 5
étoiles mais c'est clairement je pense
le palier juste en dessous dans ces
équipes qui peuvent vraiment réaliser un
coup oui bastille mode qui demandent
pourquoi la finale le 18 décembre 2022
c'est parce qu'au qatar il fait chaud et
donc c'est compliqué de jouer l'été est
donc cette compétition va se dérouler
effectivement de fin novembre à fin
décembre une collision très ramassée
dans le temps en moins d'un mois on va
faire une coupe du monde ou est tout à
fait en moins d'un mois et surtout ça va
être en plein milieu de saison donc
forcément ça va demander un petit peu de
réorganisation des calendriers donc ça
fait peut-être un petit peu drôle pour
pour les joueurs de commencer une saison
puis de partir en coupe du monde et
devoir absorber ça physiquement mais
surtout mentalement ça va être des
conditions assez assez particulière dans
un pays qu'on connaît pas beaucoup les
conditions de jeu donc on l'a dit en
termes de de météo de chaleur vont être
assez assez spéciale assez spécifique
donc ça va être assez assez particulier
maintenant on verra ce que ce que ça va
nous réserver on aille à mbouda beaucoup
de commentaires en fait sur sur le maroc
on nous demande notre avis sur le sur le
maroc pour demander à ce que je batte
que le maroc va réussir une grande coupe
du monde alors pour l'instant ont déjà
dansé pas grand-chose de deux et on n'a
pas encore les groupes aussi c'est ça
qui est important mais cette équipe du
maroc elle s'est qualifiée
là dans les éliminatoires el akel montré
de belles choses oui face au congo ça
c'est plutôt plutôt bien passé sur le
dernier match où ils menaient 4-0 un
dernier but en fin de match du congo qui
est relativement anecdotique mais sur
l'ensemble sur la cale en tout cas il se
présentait avec potentiellement la
meilleure défense de la compétition il
paraissait vraiment très solide très
rodé et au fur et à mesure ça c'est un
petit peu effilochée c'était plus
compliqué et c'est pas non plus une
équipe très impressionnante
c'est une équipe où c'est pas mal
contestée en interne on sait avec avec
vahid halilhodzic avec notamment le cas
à kim sièges qui étaient qui s'est
retrouvé écarté de la sélection et on a
un peu du mal à savoir pourquoi pourquoi
certains choix et au maroc on sait qu'il
est très contesté forcément les gens
prennent ça très très à coeur
c'est une équipe qui est quand même un
peu un piège il faudra vraiment faire le
point dans six mois parce qu'il peut se
passer beaucoup de choses d'ici là c'est
quand même une équipe à se méfier je
pense pas que c'est non plus une équipe
que la france a très envie d'avoir
honnêtement parmi les équipes du chapeau
3 je pense qu'il ya un petit peu plus
facile alors on à octave qui explique
que chaque poule est composée dernier
d'une équipe de chaque chapeau
effectivement voilà on nous parle des
équipes absent donc l'appareil de
l'algérie bien sûr de l'italie on a un
commentaire qui me dit tu parles de
ramettes rodriguez de la colombie qui ne
sera pas présent non plus la colombie
avec une grande nation d'amérique je
ramasse rodriguez qui n'est plus le
rabais sera d'ailleurs travel la coupe
du monde 2014 qui était qui était
incroyable qui avait révélé sur ce
joueur
c'est effectivement depuis la colombie
alors c'est ça reste mon équipe mais est
ce que c'est un grand absent est ce que
c'est un grand talent son adresse est
clairement pas le plus grand absent
parce que le plus grand absent on
connaît tous et un voisin de la france
maintenant oui ça reste quand même une
des équipes qui va qui va un petit peu
manqué c'est une équipe qu'on a quand
même l'habitude de voir en coupe du
monde il ya d'autres équipes on a
peut-être un petit peu mon habitude j'ai
pas ça en tête mais je pense que
l'équateur fers peu moins souvent la
coupe du monde que que la colombie le
canada pour le coup ça fait vingt ans
même plus qu'on les avait pas vus en
coupe du monde c'est vraiment un
événement pour eux de revenir donc oui
c'est un petit absents ça fait un peu
bizarre maintenant effectivement il n'ya
plus vraiment de ram est repris guedj
pas sûr qu'il ya un équivalent
actuellement en colombie qui aurait pu
faire la coupe du monde qu'elle fera
mais centrica cent en 2014
qui note qui nous dit on veut la suisse
pour la revanche
alors que le tirage au sort devrait pas
tarder à débuter là on a eu les des
andes par an on a eu d'une d'une vidéo
avec beaucoup de joueurs de football qui
ceux qui sont morts a depuis la dernière
coupe du monde on a vu par exemple
maradona samic demande à quelle heure le
tirage au sort et bien écoute ça va
démarrer mais on ne sait pas encore
exactement quand les supporters du
sénégal brésil premier zone amsud vous
n'en parlez pas on en a parlé du brésil
on peut en reparler un peu le brésil
n'est pas forcément une équipe 5 étoiles
même si elle a quand même des certitudes
mais ça reste pas aussi solide qu'une
qu'une étude comme la france par exemple
oui elle a des certitudes après comme on
a dit c'est un petit peu plus difficile
de jauger ses équipes sud américaines
parce que on le sait c'est pas du tout
une offense mais niveau et un petit peu
moindre en tout cas sur les équipes qui
est que le brésil affronte par rapport à
ce que peut-être habitués les nations
européennes
donc c'est un petit peu plus difficile
de vraiment estimer leur niveau est ce
que cette première place au classement
fifa reflète vraiment la réalité c'est
difficile à dire et donc c'est neymar
c'est censé être un petit peu le leader
de cette équipe et on voit avec le psg
il est vraiment dans le dur et ce qui
sera prêt pour la coupe du monde ça peut
jouer énormément parce qu'un brésil sans
son leader technique sans neymar c'est
difficile de les mettre dans les favoris
dans ce cas pour la coupe du monde
maintenant le brésil argentine sans
largement du jour en amérique du sud les
deux derniers finalistes de la copa
america
oui c'est clairement deux équipes je
pense en dehors des explique des équipes
européennes qui peuvent vraiment embêté
du monde maintenant est-ce qu'on peut
les mettre vraiment dans le premier lot
des favoris ça me paraît un petit peu
difficile on a vu une question sur sur
le sur le barrage qui reste en europe
écosse ukraine pays de galles est ce
qu'une équipe qui est favorite pour
arriver à la coupe du monde sachant
quand même que le pays de galles est
déjà en finale le pays de galles qui est
déjà en finale donc y attend que le
match entre l'écossé l'ukraine sera joué
ce qu'il faudra noter aussi du coup
c'est que le l'ecosse et l'ukraine vont
jouer un match entre eux et vont ensuite
enchaîné avec le pays de galles en
quarts pas vraiment de repos alors que
le pays de galles pourra justement un
petit peu se reposer un petit peu un
petit peu souffler et avoir le temps un
peu plus peut-être de préparer son match
non un favori le cas l'ukraine je pense
qu'il est impossible a analysé parce que
la condition les conditions sont trop
compliquées pour vraiment donner un avis
sur cette équipe d'ukraine mais si c'est
censé être une belle équipe on avait vu
en face à l'équipe de france maintenant
l'ecosse on l'a vu à l'euro que c'est
relativement limitées mais que ça se
connaît bien que ça s'est joué son
football et que ça peut être vraiment
solide et le pays de galles au barrage
ils ont été quand même assez
impressionnant on l'a vu gareth bale
quand il joue avec le pays de galles qui
les transcende et on retrouve le gareth
bale un petit peu qu'on a tous connu
lorsqu'il a signé au real madrid donc
c'est une équipe qui sera très difficile
à manoeuvrer si jamais si jamais elle se
qualifie alors que pendant ce temps là
sur la cérémonie on à didier deschamps
qui arrive portant la coupe du monde on
rappelle la france championne du monde
en titre qui remet son titre en jeu et
qui vient apporter cette coupe du monde
pour un tirage qui devrait débuter d'ici
quelques minutes normalement nous
n'avons pas les moyens exacte d'une
nouvelle fois je vous le dis parce que
voilà tout le monde nous demande
effectivement quand est-ce que ça
commence on ne sait pas exactement quand
ça commence c'est une cérémonie qui mots
qui prend du temps alors je vais
reprendre peut-être une note question on
nous parle du on parle du japon le japon
est ce que c'est une équipe et ce qu'est
ce qu'est ce que c'est que tu t'excuses
c'est une équipe qui peut performer
chapeau 3 on imagine que ça peut être
assez compliqué poète oui forcément un
petit peu compliqué dans le chapeau 3 et
puis parce qu'il passe d'atik c'est
forcément pas celle qu'on connaît le
plus qu'on voit le plus quand je me
souviens qu'à la coupe du monde 2018 il
a quand même pas mal embêter la belgique
ça a été un match assez fou donc sa
qualification à la dernière minute par
des serres chaudes pas d'un service et
ça je crois je montre systèmes pal en
prolongation je sais plus mais ça avait
été en tout cas extrêmement extrêmement
tendue
mais effectivement le japon c'est ça
fait partie ces équipes qu'il faut se
méfier un petit peu pour le coup comme
la corée du sud parce que ce sont des
équipes qui sont quasiment tout le temps
là
qui rate très rarement la coupe du monde
qui sont habitués en tout cas ces
matches à ce contexte maintenant on
connaît pas les situations précises en
interne du japon de la corée du sud mais
oui le japon c'est forcément inutile
dont il faut se méfier qu'on peut pas
prendre à la légère et ça envoie tous
les quatre ont alors je réponds à une
question de du chat nom n'aura pas les
images qu'on n'a pas les droits pour
diffuser ces images là évidemment mais
on vous fait vivre ne vous inquiétez pas
rester ici on fait vivre le territoire
dès qu'il commence on vous fait vivre en
direct bien sûr une question sur le
sénégal ou dit le sénégal qui est est
une équipe qui est quand même qui a
remporté la can et qui se retrouve tout
de même dans le chapeau 3 ouais alors on
le rappelle c'est parce que c'est parce
que ce ses chapeaux sont faits en
fonction du classement fifa donc ça
prend pas en compte cela juste les cinq
ou six derniers matches ça prend sur une
période beaucoup plus large et le fait
de gagner une compétition évidemment
fait marquer les points mais ne fait pas
non plus complètement décoller donc
forcément le sénégal se retrouve dans le
chapeau 3 au grain de voix c'est
vraiment le haut du chapeau 3 c'est
vraiment à la limite avec la croatie
donc ça jouerait pas grand chose et
c'est pour ça que ça se retrouve à être
une des nations qu'il vaut mieux éviter
dans le chapeau 3 effectivement alors
beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup de
questions ne pas le présent du pays bas
les pays bas on en a parlé l'allemagne
dans le chapeau 2 à éviter absolument et
peut-être juste en dessous les pays bas
quand même avec viril bandaï pendant
qu'ils aiment l'un des meilleurs
défenseurs du monde si ce n'est le
meilleur oui merci de vente d'armes
atteintes de l'irt on peut penser à un
panel de joie pour le coup du côté des
pays-bas francky de young effectivement
c'est une équipe qui se renouvelle
toujours de toute façon même s'il ya eu
de gros accroc ces dernières années pas
mal de compétitions manquer
maintenant oui c'est une des équipes je
pense les plus à redouter avec
l'allemagne dans le chapeau 2 mais
encore une fois pour l'équipe de france
je pense pas qu'ils aient vraiment
équipe qu'il faut craindre je pense que
l'équipe de france est supérieur sur le
papier absolument toutes les équipes
chapeau 2 3 4 temps dans chaque fois on
peut toujours discuter mais je pense que
pour l'équipe de france il a franchement
bien pas de me vêtir jeu alors dans les
manuels qui me manque et si on devait
choisir une petite équipe surprise de
cette coupe vaudra toujours compliqué on
a six mois qu'elle pourrait être cette
équipe surprise de la commune au total
on a parlé du canada qui a vraiment très
très bien marché en phase en phase
éliminatoire cas de la fraîcheur qu'elle
la jeunesse qui n'a pas fait la coupe du
monde depuis très longtemps donc on
n'attend pas trop normalement le
football au canada c'est pas le sport
numéro 1 donc on s'attend pas forcément
à ce soir une équipe qui performent mais
je pense qu'il faudra se méfier on verra
après en fonction du tirage au sort 2
comment cette équipe arrive c'est aussi
une équipe comme les états unis le
mexique qui va organiser la coupe du
monde en 2026 donc c'est pas non plus
une équipe qui est attendu ici qui est
sensé de performer là mais voilà c'est
une équipe c'est pour ça qu'il faut
justement s'en méfier il garde un oeil
dessus maintenant dans les équipes sinon
qu'ils peuvent un petit peut surprendre
je pense qu'il faudra se méfier du
sénégal je pense qu'il faudra s'en
méfier maintenant est ce que la suisse
peut refaire un petit peu un coup comme
à l'euro pourquoi pas de compétition de
suite ça serait quand même assez
impressionnant
voilà je pense suis sénégal canada c'est
peut-être les équipes qui peuvent un
petit peut surprendre on peut penser au
danemark dans une autre mesure parce
qu'à l'euro il ya eu vraiment une
compétition assez incroyable assez
inattendu maintenant est-ce que ce
groupe a les ressources pour rééditer un
tel exploit ils seront peut-être plus
attendus
ça demande quand même largement la
confirmation très bien effectivement on
va continuer à prendre vos questions
d'ailleurs beaucoup qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de questions dans le
chat il a dit on à une modération avec
sa chatte d'ailleurs que je remercie de
modérer tout le tous les messages il y
en avait beaucoup du coup on a on a
restreint aux abonnés de youtube donc il
voulait commenter notre live vous
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner sur notre
live youtube qirshi makindye il n'ya pas
l'australie effectivement il n'ya pas
l'australie pour l'instant l'australie
qui n'est pas pour l'instant mais qui
est en ballottage on va dire en juin qui
est qui qui jouera en juin pour sa place
la coupe du monde voilà ouais ça va
jouer ça va jouer en juin c'est une
équipe là aussi qu'on a un petit peu
comme le japon l'accord du juste une
équipe ont largement l'habitude de voir
ça pas une équipe qui a non plus une
grande ambition général en coupe du
monde on l'avait vu médaille à l'équipe
de france en 2018 si je dis pas de
bêtises on avait vu quand même vraiment
leurs limites
c'est pas une équipe qu'il faut vraiment
redouté mais voilà ça fait partie de ces
équipes on va dire qu'il fait partie a
quand même du paysage du parti presque
du phoque lors de la coupe du monde
qu'on a toujours l'habitude de voir tous
les quatre ont alors que le tiralo s'en
va commencer cette jermaine jenas qui va
qui va s'occuper de ce tirage au sort je
t'aime que je ne sais pas qui c est qui
va et qui va s'occuper de ce tirage au
sort on a ramené le ballon le le trophée
qui est sur place ça devrait démarrer
d'ici quelques minutes on nous demande
beaucoup ce qu'on pense du maroc alors
on l'a déjà dit on peut être le répéter
le maroc et après on parlera de la
belgique c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas encore
parlé de la belgique mais par contre
d'abord on va parler du maroc le maroc
on la lit qui s'est qualifiée très
récemment oui qui s'est qualifié
récemment en barrages contre contre la
république démocratique du congo donc
avec notamment un dernier match héroïque
mené 4-0 finale safina 4 1 mais c'est un
match voilà où ça n'a pas fait le congo
n'a jamais vraiment fait plus illusion
que ça c'était l'une des équipes les
plus faibles des barrages des barrages
africain maintenant le maroc qui a quand
même un petit peu déçu à la can parce
qu'on pouvait l'attendre parmi peut-être
pas les premiers favoris mais parmi la
deuxième rangée qui a une défense très
solide cas pas réussi à vraiment faire
ce pas supplémentaire ce haussement de
son niveau pour vraiment aller au bout
on l'a dit c'est une équipe qui est pas
mal critiqué au pays avec notamment
vahid halilhozic voilà il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de tension avec le cac ims
liège on a parlé c'est une équipe quand
même assez difficile à jauger qui
n'arrivent pas vraiment en pleine
confiance après encore une fois on est
en mars enfin en avril maintenant ce
sera qu'en novembre la coupe du monde il
ya du temps il peut se passer des choses
bonnes comme mauvaises mais aujourd'hui
le maroc n'est pas non plus une équipe
vraiment piège ou crossrider de cette
zone on agile qui nous parle de
parler de la belgique la belgique qui
est toujours une nation très importantes
qui arrivent quand même avec une
génération qui arrive enfin de
génération il va falloir gagner quelque
chose pour l'équipe oui il va falloir
gagner quelque chose on en parlait déjà
à l'euro 2016 on se demandait si c'était
pas un peu l'équipe qui pouvait créer la
surprise au mondial 2018 c'est insensé
un peu arrivé à maturité même à l'euro
on pouvait l'espérer maintenant voilà
c'est une équipe qui a jamais été
capable de vraiment de franchir le pas
qui a toujours eu ce petit moment de
déception mais sur son effectif / / /
leur sélectionneur aussi roberto
martinez qui est toujours en place il ya
un énorme vécu des normes expérience si
les joueurs arrivent dans de bonnes
conditions si tout se passe bien si
romelu lukaku se relance bien avec
chelsea mais qu'il arrive en bonne forme
au moment de la coupe du monde c'est
vraiment une équipe qu'on que tout le
monde je pense pour la redoute et sortir
de sortir des poules de la part de la
tunisie est-ce que c'est inimaginable
alors on ne connaît pas encore la poule
de la tunisie chapeau 3 il va falloir
quand même créé un peu la surprise oui
créer la surprise clairement parce que
c'est pas une équipe qui a attendu en 8e
de finale de coupe du monde je sais pas
je crois pas qu'ils les aient joué en
2018 c'est un groupe de l'angleterre si
je dis pas de bêtises
même si c'est une équipe qui est souvent
là qui est un petit peu qui est un petit
peu poil à gratter qui pas qu'ils pas
facile à jouer
c'est pas une équipe vraiment qu'on
attend huitièmes de finale on va pas
dire j'aime pas drôle expression de bon
tirage mais c'est peut-être franchement
le moins pire tirage du chapeau 3
charles du nid le cameroun peut-il être
la surprise on a pu voir combativité
mais quand tout était presque fini le
cameroun dans ce chapeau 4 qui sera une
équipe vraiment à à éviter par rapport
aux autres équipes oui effectivement
c'est peut-être une des équipes un petit
peu un petit peu du haut du panier en
tout cas de ce chapeau 4 je pense avec
le canada dont moi perso je préfère
vraiment me méfier maintenant le
cameroun c'est aussi une équipe qui
vient de changer de sélectionneur avec
rigobert song qui vient d'être nommé
c'est une équipe qui est clairement en
reconstruction après sa canne frustrante
forcément de ne pas avoir réussi à
gagner à domicile
est ce que c'est vraiment une équipe
dont il faut avoir peur dont il faut se
méfier il faudra pas les prendre à la
légère évidemment quoi qu'il arrive mais
c'est pas non plus vraiment une équipe
qui peut déjouer les pronostics je
pensais faire vraiment volé la vedette
en tout cas la coupe du monde en rire
humain qui lui libre pensez vous que ce
sera la dernière de 10 des gens c'est la
grande question aussi pour l'équipe de
france 10 des chansons contraste arrête
après après cette coupe du monde et on
parle de quelqu'un pour le remplacer
qu'il ya un peu connu car oui un certain
zinedine zidane alors on verra comment
comment ça se passe
maintenant actuellement c'est très très
bien pour pour dit les gens maintenant
il ya la décision qu'il est prise que
son contrat ne sera pas prolongé avant
la coupe du monde si jamais il doit être
prolongé évidemment parce que ça c'est
pas du tout sûr non plus donc qu'est-ce
que ça va dépendre des résultats en
coupe du monde ou pas est ce que gagner
la coupe du monde un nouveau offert une
excellente performance est gage de
prolongation pas forcément est ce que
didier deschamps voudra aussi continuer
et si l'estimera pas qu'il sera arrivé
ainsi va au bout de son parcours au bout
de ce qui peut tirer avec avec seconde
france donc il ya beaucoup de questions
qui entourent son avenir je pas sûr
qu'on aura une réponse dans les
prochains mois faudra vraiment attendre
octobre novembre avant peut-être d'avoir
des premières tendances et encore il
faudra peut-être attendre vraiment la
fin de la coupe du monde oui parce que
aussi il faut rappeler que je sais que
cette coupe du monde qui arrive en
novembre décembre avant les équipes
nationales a récupéré longtemps avant
les joueurs pour les faire travailler là
ce ne sera pas le cas pour cette coupe
du monde ouais tout à fait ils vont les
récupérer je crois 10 ou dix 10 jours de
semaine ou quelque chose comme ça avant
avant la coupe du monde parce que
forcément qui dit coupe du monde en
hiver dit coupe du monde plein milieu de
saison calendrier complètement chamboulé
il faut totalement se réorganiser ça
n'arrange pas du tout les clubs qui
n'ont pas très envie de libérer leurs
joueurs qui ont envie de les garder il
ya plein de matches à jouer c'est très
compliqué en termes d'organisation de
déplacer cette coupe du monde donc
forcément en terme de sélections pour le
gros pour préparer pour pour la
préparation ça va être assez assez
rock'n'roll on va dire on se rappelle
que quand le qatar avait avait des idées
la solution de faire venir la coupe du
monde en hiver a été prise après
finalement on a eu l'impression qu'ils
n'avaient pas prévu salah ben oui c'est
ça c'est que on s'est rendu compte qu'en
fait la coupe du monde a été au qatar
c'est vrai un petit peu compliqué donc
il faut tout réorganiser tout réfléchir
donc oui ça n'a pas ça n'a pas facilité
la vie de beaucoup de monde en tout cas
clairement pour pour les clubs et en
particulier pour les clubs européens oui
ça a pas mal changé leur façon de
prévoir cette saison 10 alors on a une
équipe dont on n'a pas encore parlé dans
le chapeau 1 c'est effectivement le
qatar alors quelqu'un nous aider un peu
plus haut le qatar chaque fois ça pique
les yeux mais parce que le qatar et
organisateur de cette coupe du monde
comme par exemple la russie l'avait été
et se retrouve automatiquement dans le
chapeau 1 ce qui pourrait être une
chance pour elle mais le qatar c'est
doit être une grande nation du football
oui clairement c'est pas c'est une
nation je crois qu'au terme de
classement fifa il aurait été peut-être
chapeau 3 ou quelque chose comme ça si
jamais il avait pu il avait pu jouer ils
savaient plus jouer la coupe du monde
dans des conditions normales sans être
forcément automatiquement chapeau 1 pour
pour pour pour l'organiser maintenant
est ce que c'est une équipe dont il faut
attendre grand chose est ce que c'est
une équipe dont il faut se méfier
franchement c'est une équipe qu'on
connaît pas du tout
personnellement j'ai un petit peu de
jouer contre le portugal en match amical
ce pas une équipe je pense qu'il faudra
attendre grand chose maintenant
forcément qui a tout le contexte joue à
domicile
ma première coupe du monde n'est pas
loin on sait que ça va être très très
très longtemps qu'ils n'ont pas joué
c'est très attendu le football a été
vraiment dopé ces dernières années là
bas pour être très mise en avant donc
forcément il mais c'est quand même pas
mal là dessus je pense donc forcément
ils vont vouloir jouer à coup ils vont
être un petit peu survoltée maintenant
est-ce qu'il faut s'en méfier
franchement je pense que n'importe
quelle équipe d autres chapeaux signe
demain pour jouer le qatar à la coupe du
monde certaines à qui nous parlent et le
pérou le perd on n'est pas encore
qualifié puisque le pérou se joue aussi
en juin avec les mines et des émirats
arabes unis ainsi que l'australie
on à ramdane qui nous demande varie de
l'angleterre l'angleterre qui affaire
très bon euro qui c'est qui est redevenu
la coupe du monde derrière connu on
dirait aussi fait une bonne performance
est ce que c'est le retour d'une grande
équipe anglaise
en équipe anglaise moi comme je dis je
pense que la leur aussi et pas mal de
matches à domicile et un contexte
relativement je pense favorable pour
cette équipe d'angleterre mais c'est
vrai qu'à la coupe du monde déjà il
avait eu là aussi je trouve qu'il ya eu
un parcours pas facile mais il n'y a pas
eu le parcours le plus court c'est
qu'ils soient pour se retrouver en
demi-finale avant de chuter face à face
à la croatie
maintenant oui c'est une équipe à se
méfier parce que les crèmes des grands
joueurs à quasiment tous les postes
quasiment toutes les lignes donc
forcément il faudra s'en méfier c'est
inutile surtout qu'a pu emmagasiner
beaucoup d'expérience vraiment d'avoir
vécu avec son groupe d'avoir une ferveur
populaire aussi de vraiment être soudé
et d'arriver plus tôt dans de bonnes
conditions à cette coupe du monde
maintenant est ce que dans ce contexte
forcément différent avec les joueurs
qu'ils ont est ce que on peut les mettre
vraiment dans les plu aux favoris je
pense quand même par exemple c'est quand
même un cran en dessous de l'équipe de
france bonsant la cérémonie on est en
train de voir les derniers préparatifs
la fifa est en train d'expliquer comment
vont être faits le tirage au sort alors
on l'a expliqué déjà il y a quatre
chapeaux une équipe de chaque chapeau
dans chaque groupe pour ensuite alors
les chapeaux bien sûr il ya le kata
ensuite il y a les suites tout est
classé en fonction du classement fifa
sauf pour les équipiers toujours pas
encore qualifié et on l'a dit tout le
monde dans le japon on peut affronter
chapeau 2 chapeautera chapeau 4 sauf pas
n'est pas la même fédération a pris à
l'exception bien sûr de l'europe parce
qu'il ya plus de nations européennes qui
nie à deux groupes donc on aura
forcément des groupes avec deux nations
européennes maintenant oui effectivement
par exemple pour prendre un exemple de
sénégal ne pourra pas être dans le même
groupe que le cameroun le japon ne
pourrait pas être dans le même groupe
que l'arabie saoudite donc forcément ça
va un petit peu orienté le tirage au
sort
maintenant ça va pas révolutionner grand
chose ça ne change pas grand chose je
pense pour pour l'équipe de france en
fin de compte surtout que pour l'équipe
de france basse avec passe quand même se
retrouver avec une équipe comme
l'allemagne ou les pays-bas donc c'est
sûr tout ça et vite et en tout cas pour
l'équipe de france effectivement alors
beaucoup de beaucoup de commentaires sur
un plan clair on ne parle de la tunisie
se passionna au déjà paraître la tunisie
parce que est ce que est ce que la
tunisie pourrait être pour être une
surprise dans ce mondial ouais on l'a
dit un petit un petit mot c'est un peu
c'est un peu difficile de les jauger en
tout cas c'est pas une équipe dont on
attend un grand chose c'est pas du tout
une équipe habituée aux huitièmes de
finale même si c'est une équipe qu'on
passait régulièrement en coupe du monde
on les a vus à la can ils sont pas du
tout sortis du lot mais s'il y avait eu
des conditions assez peu favorable pour
le coup avec des éditions arbitrage
décision d'arbitrage parfois vraiment
qui leur sont tombés dessus est vraiment
ils n'ont pas eu de chance
maintenant même en barrages ils ont
sorti le congo c'est pas non plus une
référence sur le continent africain donc
ce n'est pas une équipe qui a vraiment
beaucoup de garanties qui a pas de très
grands joueurs
non c'est pas une équipe dont on attend
grand chose si jamais ils sortent en
huitièmes de finale s'ils arrivent
jusqu'aux huitièmes de finale
franchement on verra selon groupe mais
ce serait déjà un petit exploit très
bien alors pendant ce temps là on nous
explique comment le dire est ce parce
qu'effectivement avec toutes ces
exceptions qui ont été mises on part sur
un tirage qui est assez compliquée et on
l'a vécue il ya pas si longtemps avec un
talent je lis des géorgiens ça peut être
problématique ce genre de choses oui ça
peut être problématique donc on espère
qu'on aura pas revenir à 22h pour
refaire un tirage au sort normalement ça
va ça va bien se passer mais
effectivement il ya aussi certaines
questions que la fifa n'a pas trop
élucidés notamment sur sur les équipes
qui ne sont pas encore qualifiés selon
la zone selon la confédération comment
ça va s'organiser et ce qu'ils ont déjà
anticipé les choses est ce que le pérou
par exemple se retrouver avec une autre
nation sud américaine à cause du fait
qu'elle n'est pas encore officiellement
qualifiés enfin même qu'elle n'est pas
qualifié du tout parce qu'elle aura un
match à jouer forcément
bon oui c'est un tirage au sort un petit
peu un petit peu compliqué maintenant en
tout cas sur les trois premier chapeau
devrait pas y avoir trop de problèmes ça
devrait pouvoir se faire à peu près
proprement après c'est sûr le quatrième
que ça a posé souci mais même sur ce je
vous rappelle que pour la ligue des
champions ça avait l'air aussi facile et
pour autant la dure faire ce tirage
qu'il était mal placé je vois qu'il ya
déjà des commentaires qui commence à
stresser
emmanuel qui me dit qu'il regrette deux
équipes donc la colombie dont a parlé le
nigeria le nigeria zippers humaine qui
n'a pas passé les barrages ouais le
nigeria assez surprenante grand habitué
de la coupe du monde qui avait joué dans
l'équipe de france notamment si je me
trompe pas star huitièmes de finale en
2018 donc oui c'est un singe habitués
pour le coup une équipe qui s'invite
parfois de temps en temps en phase
finale oui ça fait partie effectivement
tsé-tsé absent à la coupe alors que le
tirage a commencé donc le qatar a été
tirée et le qatar devrait arriver
normalement dans le groupe a vu que
c'est le pays organisateur le pays qui
démarrera cette coupe du monde on vous
l'a dit alors je vais vous redonner la
date qui est sur mon ordinateur le 21
novembre voilà le kata et bien au groupe
pour l'instant tout jusque là ça va
jusque là ça va et c'est peut-être
maintenant que ça va se ça va se
compliquer petit à petit avec le
deuxième la deuxième équipe qui va être
tirée on rappelle aussi que là on va
avoir les équipes qu'on va pouvoir
savoir déjà à peu près aux huitièmes de
finale par exemple selon le groupe a ou
b et c l'angleterre qui a attiré
l'angleterre
on voit on voit le sélectionneur de
l'angleterre d'ailleurs qui est là on en
parlait tout à l'heure l'angleterre qui
pourrait faire quand même une belle
blonde après son vélo ouais
effectivement l'angleterre de gareth
southgate ça se passe pas trop mal en
tout cas pour eux depuis depuis l'euro
il a été maintenu en poste on pouvait se
poser la question s'ils seraient gardés
si lui-même voudrait voudrais rester
après lui l'énorme désillusion de la
défaite aux tirs au but à domicile en
finale de l'euro face à face à l'italie
maintenant oui c'est une équipe qui a
fait demi finale de coupe du monde qui a
fait une finale d'euro qui maintenant
connais un petit peu le chemin qui
connaît un petit peu tout ce contexte
c'est une équipe clairement quand il
faudra se méfier avec deux trois joueurs
de classe mondiale à différents postes
l'angleterre dans le groupe b
l'angleterre dans le groupe b c'est
quand même pas mal non plus pour réussir
si ce groupe vu que ce groupe a croisé
avec le groupe du qatar ça enlève déjà
un gros on va dire oui voilà ça enlève à
gros puisque normalement si si tout se
passe bien ce sera le premier du groupe
a contre le 2e du groupe b en huitièmes
de finale et inversement donc
effectivement ça enlève déjà un gros
potentiellement pour l'équipe de france
a joué en ficelle de films c'est
l'argentine qui vient d'être tiré
l'argentine de lionel messi qui était
chapois l'argentine qui a qui reste
aussi une valeur sûre même si on bat
avec une star ac vieillissante oui ça
c'est vieillissante et un leader
clairement dans le dur en ce moment au
psg après encore une fois dans six mois
six mois c'est très long sinon il peut
se passer beaucoup de choses mais si
vraiment bien revenir est arrivé avec
une plus grande fraîcheur une meilleure
une meilleure forme plus d'énergie donc
on verra comment ça se passera pour lui
au delà de messi c'est quand même une
équipe qu'il faut forcément redouté
c'est une équipe tenant du titre en copa
america ce communiqué contient certains
repères mais bon on va attraper des bons
souvenirs puisque c'est la france qui
l'a étiré au pour le groupe donc la
france dé tirer dans le groupe des docks
lll sera elle sera dans ce groupe et en
cas de huitième de finale imaginons que
l'argentine arrive en demi finale arrive
deuxième où la france termine deuxième
et donc pour avoir un petit remake du
huitième de finale d'il ya quatre ans
oui exactement pourrait on pourrait
avoir ça ça serait quand même une grosse
surprise une vraie déception si une de
ces deux équipes fini deuxième de son
groupe mais effectivement c'est une
possibilité donc on va forcément
surveiller maintenant un peu le groupe d
évidemment mais aussi le groupe c'est
parce que le potentiel adversaire de la
france en huitièmes de finale se
trouvera dans ce compte effectivement
donc la france qui vient d'être tiré je
vois sacha dans le chat qui nous dit
fectivement que c'est le 22 novembre
bien évidemment le premier match de la
france donc 22 novembre même on peut
vous donner les autres matches 22
novembre 26 novembre et le dernier match
sera le 30 novembre pour le match
l'équipe de france de la coupe du monde
puisque vous êtes déjà le calendrier est
disponible il manquait juste les équipes
c'est l'espagne qui va être tirée dans
le groupe e on l'a dit l'espagne une
équipe assez jeune rajeunie qui pourrait
elle aussi poser des soucis à beaucoup
d'équipés way qui pourrait embêter
beaucoup d équipes on l'avait alors on
les attendait pas forcément parce qu'on
savait que c'était une équipe en
reconstruction
beaucoup de jeunes joueurs on se
demandait si des leaders elle est
vraiment se dégage et surtout dans le
domaine offensif
on a vu que c'était le cas on voit des
joueurs qui prennent une nouvelle
dimension que ce soit en club ou en
sélection je pense à faire un torres le
barcelonais pédri dans la même équipe
gérard moreno qui s'affirme vraiment
avec villarreal
c'est une équipe oui on sera obligé de
se méfier
maintenant on verra il ya encore
quelques doutes sur certains postes
c'est qu'ils cherchent encore un petit
peu même si elle connaît toujours son
football qu'on a l'habitude depuis
maintenant 10 15 ans donc on verra mais
oui ça fait partie potentiellement de ce
premier lot de favori un couteau alors
la belgique qu'il a d'être tirés qui va
qui va atterrir dans le groupe f alors
c'est un peu compliqué de répondre à vos
questions en suivant alors on va parler
de toutes les équipes à chaque fois
qu'elles sont on veut qu'elles ont tiré
mais voilà on promis on va essayer de
parler de toutes vos équipes pour vous
le prouver donc la belgique dans le
groupe f on l'a dit la belgique qu'il
faut il faut pas que il faut pas rater
sa chance une nouvelle fois oui il faut
pas rater sa chance parce qu'à un moment
donné ils sont déjà laissé le bus passé
plusieurs fois on l'a dit à l'euro 2016
coupe du monde 2018 ou 2020
il est temps quand même pour cette pour
cette génération d'enfin d'enfin se se
récompenser le titre alors on va pas
faire d' europe allait trop loin non
plus dans la dans la prospective mais
sachez que si on essore premier de la
poule d en quart de finale on pourrait
jouer contre le premier de la groupe du
groupe et donc d'autres l angleterre on
pourrait le avoir un premier choc france
angleterre on n'en est pas du tout
encore là mais bon on peut quand même
déjà en parler up oui voilà c'est un
petit peu les projections déjà qu'on
qu'on pourra faire bas disent y est allé
d'une demi heure on va dire on pourra
déjà faire si on veut tous tableau
dessiné un petit peu tout ce qu'on veut
fantasme est déjà un petit peu sur les
quarts de finale demi finale potentiel
final on pourra avoir un talus l'idée
générale est donc le brésil qui est dans
le groupe g et donc il ne reste plus que
le portugal qui va se retrouver dans le
groupe h c'est quel jour le coup d'envoi
de la coupe du monde alors le coup
d'envoi de la coupe du monde c'est le 18
novembre si je ne me trompe pas 10 21
novembre à 7 18 décembre la fin et 21
novembre le début avec un match du qatar
on va en va d'ailleurs découvrir cette
première affiche dans quelques temps
puisque ce sera la première équipe qui
sera tiré
dans le groupe du qatar qu'il affrontera
le le deuxième chapeau parce qu'il faut
quand même avoir une c'est le pays
organisateur il faut une affiche donc tu
aura quand même un peu un gros dans ce
match oui voilà en principe ça sera
quand même une belle équipe après on l'a
dit dans le chapeau 2 allée c'est une
équipe qui est un petit peu en dessous
de l'eau peut-être les états unis mais
même les états unis restent quand même
une équipe forcément prendre au sérieux
dans tous les cas on va normalement avec
la prochaine équipe connaître la
première affiche de la coupe du monde le
match d'ouverture alors on nous parle du
des horaires des matchs donc ce sera 13
heures pour le match d'ouverture heure
locale donc à chaque fois je crois que
ces deux heures de plus alors n'attendez
plus jeune et plus ou moins exacts mais
en te voilà alors vous vois je vais pas
vous dire de ne pas vous avez dit mais
oui alors si il me semble que c'est bien
deux heures de décalage ou à chaque fois
donc 6 et 13 heures ça fait 15 heures 21
heures puis
le deuxième match sera donc à 21h il ya
des matches à 16 heures donc ça les
amène à 18 heures les pays-bas pays-bas
première équipe qui est première équipe
tous tirer les pays-bas alors cette
partie du tirage dure à peu près bien se
passer c'est après que les choses vont
se compliquer on l'a fait avec toutes
les petites règles voilà c'est ça avec
notamment le fait que deux équipes d'une
même confédération ne peuvent pas
s'affronter à l'exception des européens
puisqu'il ya plus de nations européennes
que deux groupes mais voilà par exemple
si on prend un petit exemple l'uruguay
ne pleurera pas tomber dans le groupe du
brésil normalement c'est pas possible on
a un commentaire qui me dit tant qu'on
dévie de la suisse ça me va je pense que
c'est un français qui veut éviter l'euro
et donc les pays bas qui se retrouve
dans le groupe a avec le qatar et qui
seront pas alors j'ai dit une bêtise
tout à l'heure ils ne seront pas
deuxième alors on tire ensuite alors
d'abord en fait là une première fois on
tire l'équipe puis elle arrive dans le
groupe et ensuite on tire sa position de
groupe et donc là le pays bas les pays
bas ne seront au saut à 4 donc ce sera
la quatrième équipe du groupe en fait ce
qu'il veut dire qu'on n'aura pas un
qatar pays bas donc un match en mains
dès l'ouverture on aura donc une autre
affiche avec le qatar toulouse
effectivement et la cdc les etats-unis
qui viennent d'être tirées les états
unis on rappelle qu'ils sont l'équipe un
peu abordable de ce groupe oui c'est
potentiellement l'équipe la moins forte
sur sur le papier pas été une mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'équipe de france oui
c'est probablement l'équipe qu'on
attende pas trop en tout cas dans ce
chapeau 2 il ya quasiment toutes les
autres nations qu'on attend qu'on attend
plus avec le mexique peut-être c'est
quand même les deux nations qui sont un
petit cran dessous effectivement donc le
donc les états unis qui vont se
retrouver dans le groupe b en position 3
états unis angleterre donc qui se
on est sur un petit groupe anglo anglais
et voilà pour l'instant pour l'instant
en termes de langue ils n'auront pas de
problème à se comprendre sur le terrain
en tout cas si jamais si elles veulent
changer les amabilités ça y aura aucun
aucun souci une fois qu'ils seront qui
secoue la peau clignote coquine date ce
qui nous dit les gars qui n'ont toujours
pas compris qu'on ne peut pas rencontrer
des équipes de notre chapeau
effectivement chaque équipe joue contre
une équipe de son chapeau excusez moi on
ne peut pas affronter une même équipe de
son chapeau bien évidemment le mexique
le mexique ça nous intéresse le mexique
va jouer contre l'argentine et c'est le
chapeau donc c'est à priori la deuxième
plus grosse équipe du groupe c ce sera
le déclic est donc un potentiel
adversaire pour la pour les huitièmes de
finale pour la france sachant que le
mexique on n'a pas encore on n'a pas
encore trop parlé le mes clips foot
quand même toujours un peu s'en méfier
oui il faut toujours se méfier un petit
peu comme les états unis ce n'est pas
une équipe qu'on peut prendre à la
légère maintenant c'est l'équipe en
éliminatoires qui a failli non plus une
énorme impression en tout cas en
éliminatoires l'équipe est un peu sorti
du lot en concacaf c'est plutôt le
canada maintenant forcément il n'y a pas
de matches faciles à la coupe du monde
c'est c'est enfoncer des portes ouvertes
mais c'est une réalité évidemment le
mexique ce soit l'argentine du mexique
ça sera un vrai morceau pour l'équipe de
france en 8e de finale si c'est une de
ces deux équipes bien sûr alors vous
êtes prêt de près de 5000 à nous suivre
c'est énorme merci rester avec nous
surtout on va voir quelle équipe va
jouer contre la france quelle équipe va
être tiré au sort pour jouer contre la
france et on peut voir même vous donner
la date de ce match puisque ce sera dans
le groupe d ce sera le danemark le
danemark donc france danemark j'ai
l'impression que france danemark c'est
un peu un classique ouais ouais c'est
maintenant un petit peu un petit peu un
classique les gens en 2018
c'est un adversaire difficile à à jauger
parce qu'on a vu à l'euro ou le danemark
était vraiment impressionnant après
évidemment il y avait sept ce malaise
cardiaque de christiane ericsson qui
avait peut-être aussi dynamiser le
groupe qu'il avait soudé qui a provoqué
un élan qu'on ne soupçonnait pas en tout
cas on n'imaginait pas au début de la
compétition le danemark en demi finale
de l'euro s'était pas du tout ce qui
était attendu pas sur papier
maintenant on verra ce que peut nous
réserver le danemark évidemment c'est
inutile qu'on va énormément regardez
maintenant d'ici à la coupe du monde
c'est quand même pas non plus un cadeau
pour l'équipe de france n'était pas une
petite équipe de ce chapeau 2 donc
france danemark ce sera le 26 novembre
2022 après je crois que le match se
déroulera à minuit de ce que je de ce
que je vois sur le site que je suis en
train de regarder donc france danemark
en suisse et l'allemagne ou allemagne
espagne on a mano de groupe de la mort
je crois oui on a peut-être un début de
groupe de la mort là parce que
l'espagne on se posait la question
est-ce que c'est dans ces équipes cinq
étoiles qui sont vraiment dans le
premier lot des favoris et l'allemagne
je pense qu'ils ne sont peut-être encore
plus en fait que l'espagne misera pu
être inversée au niveau des chapeaux
serait pas du tout était était était
absurde donc oui là c'est un énorme choc
déjà en phase de groupes effectivement
donc espagne espagne allemagne dès le
début enfin voilà ans après voilà
l'équipe qui tire l albanais c'était à
priori pour elle le groupe de la mort
c'est un type de saint louis alors on va
regarder quelle équipe il reste attiré
il reste l'uruguay il nous reste la
suisse il nous reste la croatie je crois
donc l'uruguay ne pourra pas tomber
contre le brésil par exemple on va
commencer à commandes ont commencé à
faire des calculs ça exactement c'est
parti et on va voir la route qui va être
tirée à l'instant pas
attention et nous avons donc la croatie
la croatie avec avec la belgique ouais
là aussi c'est quand même très une très
belle affiche de phase de poules la
croatie on se rappelle finaliste de la
dernière coupe du monde le rose ça a été
un peu plus difficile forcément est ce
que c'est une équipe dont il faut
vraiment se méfier c'est difficile à
dire en tout cas normalement pour la
belgique
il faut pas que ça fasse faut pas que ça
soit une mauvaise blague la belgique est
normalement clairement supérieure on a
dit la belgique a doit enfin concrétisé
doit enfin franchir ce cap est allé au
bout d'une compétition parce que on
l'attend depuis depuis maintenant cinq
ou six ans tnm plus depuis l'euro 2016
voire mais la coupe du monde 2014 déjà
où il a été impressionnant on les
attendait pas aussi tôt mais il avait
déjà performé il sera temps pour la
belgique de performer et normalement
c'est pas là cognitives comme la croatie
qui doit qui doit la reprise et leurs
rêves ils sont ils seront clairement
favoris face oui oui clairement
clairement je pense qu' il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'équipés quelques équipes dans
le chapeau 1 qui ne sont qui serait
peut-être qui pourrait vraiment
rivaliser avec la belgique mais sur
papier la belgique fait clairement
partie des favoris de cette coupe du
monde alors on va voir si le tirage au
sort se passe bien puisque l'uruguay
vient d'être retirée et le à l'uruguay
ne pourra pas jouer contre le brésil
donc si tout se passe bien l'uruguay
devrait être reversé dans le groupe h
avec le portugal pendant que la suisse
devra jouer contre contre le brésil
brésil suisse quand même le brésil sera
favori oui bien sûr le brésil sera
favori après la suisse on a vu que
signifie qu'on attendait franchement pas
à l'euro ils ont surpris beaucoup de
monde face à l'équipe de france et même
au tour suivant si je dis pas belliciste
à contrôler l'espagne où ils ont
énormément tenu tête je crois que ça
s'est joué en prolongation
donc donc oui c'est une équipe
évidemment dont brésil devra se méfier
mais normalement il ya quand même une
petite classe d'écart entre les deux
portugal uruguay portugal et l'uruguay
alors on va regarder avant le match en
match avancé tirage au sort le dernier
match de l'uruguay il ils ont une équipe
qui a quand même assez vieillissante
avec des petits nouveaux qu'on ne
connaît pas forcément nous en europe oui
voilà certains joueurs c'est un petit
peu un petit peu sous les radars qui
bouge ou peut-être en europe et encore
pas toujours certains qui jouent en
argentine qu'on ne connaît pas forcément
et surtout des joueurs oui effectivement
c'est viellissant diego godinette encore
la luis suarez edinson cavani maintenant
ils ont une génération quand même qui
pousse un petit peu je pense à rigaud
bettencourt de la juventus surtout
darwin moon est ce qui est censé être la
relève en attaque de cavani suarez le
joueur de benfica donc oui c'est une
équipe c'est quand même franchement un
cran en dessous en amérique du sud
aujourd'hui du brésil et de l'argentine
si je me rappelle bien ils ont fait
quarts de finale en copa america sac à
main un petit peu déçu quand même passé
un peu un côté
normalement pour le portugal sur le
papier le portugal est censé être favori
maintenant on l'a dit le portugal c'est
une équipe qui est un petit peu déçu sur
ses belles images comme beaucoup de
fébrilité qui n'assument pas vraiment
son statut de nouveau cador qui ne
profite pas de sa sa force offensive
absolument incroyable sur le papier mais
normalement portugal est censé être au
dessus de le rue avec chose ne va pas
encore parler mais ça on n'en parlera
bien sûr à la fin du tirage c'est ce
groupe belgique croatie avec la belgique
est favorite s'ils terminent premiers
ils vont croiser avec le groupe
espagne albanie exactement ça peut être
vraiment des huitièmes de finale de la
mort pour le coup ça peut ça peut
s'enchaîner assez vite et pour la
belgique bat on en parlait que oui
génération qui doit confirmer il risque
d'avoir si jamais il se qualifier en 8e
de finale déjà un très très gros morceau
alors dans les commentaires on a demandé
quel était le groupe le plus le plus
relevé à priori pour vous c'est le
espagne espagne allemagne c'est ce
groupe là qui selon vous est le plus le
plus relevé alors que l'iran vient
d'être tiré dans le dans le chapeau 3 vu
commander maintenant au chapeau 3 les
deux premier chapeau ont été vidés les
groupes commencent à prendre forme et
donc c'est l'iran qui a retiré donc si
j'ai bien suivi l'iran ne peut pas jouer
contre le qatar qui sont la même
fédération et arrivera dans le groupe b
avec l'angleterre états unis voilà c'est
exactement ce qu'ils devraient ce qui
devrait se passer donc maintenant un
petit peu forcément le piège des
confédérations parce que l'on va avoir
de plus en plus maintenant qu'il ya de
plus en plus des équipes qui sont qui
sont tirées donc effectivement l'iran
dans le oui dans groupe b avec
l'angleterre et les états unis on a dit
que l'iran sur le chapeau 3 franchement
c'est pas une équipe dont il faut il
faut beaucoup redoutent et si tenté
qu'il ya vraiment des équipes qui
peuvent faire très peur dans le chapeau
3 on a dit que le sénégal peut-être sort
du lot le sénégal de sadio man et
maintenant pour l'angleterre c'est là
aussi une équipe largement à sa portée
on verrait clip du chapeau 4 mai en
angleterre doit finir première de sa
poule on parle et on ouvre on parlait
iran etats unis pour la france ça serait
un groupe facile c'est pour l'angleterre
oui voilà c'est pour l'angleterre qui
pour l'instant oui s'en sort bien plutôt
la chance de son côté si tenté que il ya
une notion de chance et le sénégal qui
va être retiré le sénégal qui va donc
arriver sur le groupe a avec le qatar et
les pays bas un petit pays bas sénégal
ça risque d'être sympa ça à regarder oui
ça peut être ça peut être un petit peu
serré c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
le qatar s'ils avaient vraiment envie de
réussir un coup parce que le sénégal à
venir avec de vraies ambitions en tant
que champion d'afrique en titre avec un
ca djoman et qui dans le meilleur
football de sa carrière sûrement
donc c'est pas c'est pas un cadeau ni
pour ni pour qatar ni pour les pays bas
effectivement alors que la prochaine
équipe qui va être tirée ça va se passer
dans quelques secondes on va voir quelle
équipe alors pendant ces leucémies c'est
la position donc c'est à 3 à 3 pour le
sénégal donc on n'a toujours pas le
match d'ouverture du kusadasi le ça veut
dire qu'on a toujours pas mal de verdure
on aura tout à la fin donc ce sera le
qatar contre une petite équipe du
chapeau une petite équipe attention je
ne peux pas faire offense à l'équipe qui
va être retirée mais ça va être ça va
pas être le grand choc qui va démarrer
cette coupe du monde non ça passe ça va
pas être un match incroyable a priori tu
pars avec des grandes stars mais
n'est-ce pas toujours le cas d'ailleurs
je crois en match d'ouverture parfois on
a des matches sur papier un petit peu
moins sexy mais l'important c'est plus
la cérémonie d'ouverture ce jour a
parfois quelques vrais mon premier match
le sénégal qui nous qui donc va jouer
dans le groupe à et qui finalement s'en
servent pas si mal aussi parce que du
coup une vraie chance de qualité pour
les victimes oui une vraie chance
potentiellement on avait dit que
n'importe quelle équipe rêve de tomber
avec le qatar s'il faut tomber à une
équipe du chapeau 1 parce qu'on n'y
échappe pas évidemment bas le qatar est
largement largement moins fort que
toutes les autres équipes donc oui
l'équipe qui se retrouve dans le groupe
à pour l'e3 dernier chapeau est
généralement l'équipe qui est un petit
peu gagné le gros lot on va dire alors
que c'est la pologne qui va être retirée
à wohlen qui va jouer contre l'argentine
et le mexique ça aussi pour la deuxième
place a alors expliqué intéresse la
france ça va être quand même très
intéressant ouais jusqu'ici on pourrait
dire que c'est assez homogène en tout
cas entre le mexique et la pologne est
ce qu'il ya vraiment une équipe
largement au dessus de l'autre alors le
mexique quand même marqué beaucoup de
points au classement uefa qui était
alors pas loin non plus de se retrouver
dans le chapeau 1 la pologne lundi qu'il
ya pas mal d sion barrage qui a quand
même assez déçu aussi sur sa phase
éliminatoire certain robert lewandowski
mais malheureusement sur collectif ça
suit pas beaucoup c'est une équipe qui a
pas franchement de garantie qui est pas
habitué à vraiment à faire des coups
déjà à l'euro 2016 qui avait fait un
quart de finale face au portugal
jusqu'aux tirs au but et ça avait été
déjà presque un exploit pour eux
d'arriver aussi loin
maintenant c'est pas une équipe
franchement qu'on attend beaucoup à
cette coupe du monde bien aidés vivement
alors que c'est la serbie qui vient
d'être tiré la serbie ne peut pas jouer
contre d'un groupe d ninon regroupe dans
le groupe f puisque il a trop d'équipés
européennes donc ce sera dans le groupe
g brésil suisse est servie puisque on
vous le rappelle effectivement tout de
même le on peut avoir deux équipes
européennes mais pas de 3 oui voilà on
pourra pas en avoir on pourra pas en
avoir 3 2 équipes européennes on le
rappelle parce qu'il ya plus de l'action
européenne que de gros je crois qu'il ya
douze ou treize nations je crois que
c'est 12
d'herbe brésil serbie je crois qu'il ya
déjà eu ça y'a pas longtemps au coude
gauche s'était pas déjà le cas en 2018
même un brésil suite je crois qu'on a eu
aujourd'hui si longtemps je pense qu à
nyala alors là ça va intéresser la
france puisque ce ça devrait être oui ça
va être une équipe contre qui ils
apprendre à jouer japon maroc que c'est
la tunisie la tunisie pour la france
tunisie france danemark dans le groupe b
ouais la tunisie ben on en parlait tout
à l'heure on disait que c'était
peut-être l'équipe l'équipe la moins
forte en tout cas sur papier sur sur ce
chapeau 3 évidemment creully fois c'est
c'est une lapalissade mais il n'y a pas
de match à prendre à la légère il n'y a
pas de match facile maintenant sur la
tunisie c'est pas une équipe qui a
beaucoup de références beaucoup de
garanties qui a pas du tout impressionné
à l'as cannes nice aux éliminatoires ni
sur ces barrages face au congo c'est pas
des victoires références non plus cette
victoire au match retour face au congo 4
1 c'est pas grande victoire parce que le
congrès était un adversaire relativement
faible à l'échelle de même de l'afrique
maintenant c'est une équipe faudra quand
même prendre au sérieux c'est quand même
franchement pour l'instant en assez bon
tirage pour l'équipe de france france
tunisie le match alors elle a été tirée
en 4 d-4d 1 contre des quatre se
produira le 30 novembre 2022 ce match
entre la france et la tunisie alors
bravo quand même sébastien puisque servi
brésil suisse son mec c'était déjà
2 le 2 la coupe du monde alors brésil
suisse et un en 2018 et brésil serbie
aussi il y avait dix avaient déjà groupe
avec ces trois équipes
l'assemblée au brésil ça va être des
retrouvailles du coup
je dois bien sûr qu'ils connaissent un
petit fait maintenant fait arrêter à ces
pratiques alors que le japon le japon
viennent malheureusement alors
malheureusement on ne sait pas mais avec
l'espagne et l'allemagne dans ce groupe
de la mort qu'il complète alors on n'a
pas très gros du chapeau 3 donc
peut-être que des bailleurs deux équipes
qui vaut largement se détachent les
autres well japon c'était un peu un peu
un peu dur de les jauger parce que c'est
pas dit ce qu'il veut qu'on connaît très
très bien c'est une équipe qui souvent
là mais qui est rarement huitièmes de
finale même si l'on est et je crois
qu'en 2018 du coup contre la belgique où
ils sont et elle s'était fait sortir
vraiment sur le fil par par la belgique
il avait vraiment fait trembler
maintenant oui clairement deux équipes
qui sont largement du lot pour l'instant
dans ce groupe alors on nous rappelle
effectivement les usa et son revenu ne
vous inquiétez pas il avait disparu du
tableau mais ils sont toujours là dans
le groupe b avec l'iran et l'angleterre
alors que c'est le maroc qui vient
d'être retirée le maroc qui va se
retrouver avec la belgique et la croatie
webb a frôlé le maroc on en a pas mal
parlé tout à l'heure équipe difficile à
jauger il faudra vraiment attendre dans
six mois parce qu'il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses une équipe assez
critiqué au pays
ouais c'est un peu un peu difficile de
vraiment donner un avis clair clair
là-dessus
tout cas avec la belgique à la croatie
là aussi un peu comme espagne allemagne
japon quand même deux équipements
allemands qui sortent du lot qui sont
qui seront attendus en tout cas au
rendez vous des huitièmes de finale
au maroc c'est pas vraiment le groupe le
groupe rennais et la corée du sud qui
est la dernière équipe tirait avec le
portugal et l'uruguay dans le groupe h
corée du sud et uruguay pour le portugal
c'est le portugal est normalement au
dessus de ces deux équipes là mais ça
ressemble quand même à deux beaux pièges
oui de pau piège parce que la corée du
sud on l'a dit c'est une équipe qui
monte jamais quasiment la coupe du monde
qui connecte à un petit peu tout cet
univers tout ce contexte tous ses
matches de poule
c'est un peu l'équipe piège parce qu'on
la connaît pas beaucoup parce qu'on sait
pas vraiment ce qu'elle vaut maintenant
normalement sur le papier une équipe
assez nettement en dessous un cran en
dessous du portugal et même du lourd
donc c'est l'équipe de accords étude a
été tirée il rigolait portugal donc là
on a les groupes qui commence à prendre
forme on va passer au chapeau 4 le
cameroun le canada l'équateur l'arabie
saoudite le ghana et les trois équipes à
déterminer on vous expliquera sa tout ou
bien quand on dirait et on va bien voir
ce que ça va donner en terme de tirage
parce que là pour l'instant c'était à
peu près facile c'est maintenant que ça
va aussi se compliquer pour réussir à
faire rentrer un peu tout le monde de
tout le monde dans les cases le cameroun
ne peut déjà pas aller dans le groupe à
le canada ne pourra pas être dans le
groupe b voilà ça va nini dans le groupe
c'est donc qui va commencer à voir
quelques petits ça va aller assez vite
finalement parce qu'il ya pas mal de
possibilités qui ne sont qu' il n'existe
pas en fait donc forcément les ce qu'il
faut être assez vite finalement attribué
dans les coupes chaud patate qui nous
dit est-ce que c'est pas un peu facile
pour les anglais ce tirage on l'a dit
iran usa c'était les deux équipes à
prendre la peau de chat potro a priori
oui potentiellement oui pour beaucoup en
tout cas je pense que les etats unis tel
un cran en dessous de la plupart des
autres sauf peut-être le mexique dans le
chapeau 2
où il prend son souffle d'un tirage
largement abordable pour l'angleterre
alors c'est c'est une équipe de playoffs
alors je sais pas laquelle ça va être
par contre parce que je n'ai pas la
différence entre les deux sur mon
tableau mais c est donc ce sera pour la
france alors la france va jouer contre
une équipe de kiev alors il faudrait que
je vais essayer de vous retrouver
l'information parce que pour l'instant
je ne l'est pas
puisque je ne vois pas quel laquelle ça
va être pour l'instant je suis en train
de chercher en même temps pour voir quel
prix en fait les équipes donc on a d'un
côté la nouvelle zélande et
et le costa rica et de l'autre australie
père aux émirats arabes unis donc s'il y
en a yala et lancer les deux et je vous
avoue que je ne sais pas exactement
lequel et le quai c'est pour la spa ça
va être très particulier du coup pour
l'équipe de france qui du coup n'a en
fait ne connaît pas tous ses adversaires
encore à la coupe du monde donc il
faudra patienter jusqu'au jusqu'au mois
de juin au mois de juin où il y aura ces
barrages intercontinentaux qu'à ce
moment là on saura enfin qui qui est
qualifiée qui qui vraiment affronte qui
effectivement l'équateur vient d'être
retirée l'équateur qui normalement tu
vas rejoindre le groupe à un groupe avec
le qatar sénégal pays bas equateur
ouais l'équateur c'était un peu un peu
difficile vraiment de donner un avis là
dessus parce que est ce que c'est être
ni une équipe facile ni difficile dans
ce chapeau 4 c'est un petit peu un petit
peu au milieu maintenant ça fait un
groupe j'allais dire homogène mais
normalement si on a deux favoris c'est
quand même les pays bas et le sénégal le
samu il ya quand même plutôt son destin
entre ses mains j'ai envie de dire sur
le papier pour se qualifier pour les
huitièmes de finale effectivement alors
le coup le tirage au sort qui se
poursuit l'équateur donc qui va
rejoindre le groupe alors ce sera donc à
qatar équateur pour ouvrir c'est cette
coupe du monde une affiche qui n'a pas
dû se produire très souvent au coeur
non non qu'on voit pas souvent la coupe
du monde que ceux de nation fait qu'on
ne voit pas souvent à la coupe du monde
tout simplement le qatar ça fait très
très longtemps je crois qu'il n'avait
pas joué je pense qu'ils ont déjà joué
vraiment faire un petit moment et
l'équateur ah c'est pas non plus un
quant à bitche et en amérique du sud je
en train de voir si il existe déjà un
match qui était qui a été joué à 4 3 qui
a eu lieu en 2018 le qatar qui avait
gagné 4-3 contre courant course
d'équateur donc ils ne se seront
affrontés il n'y a pas si longtemps que
ça l'arabie saoudite l'arabie saoudite
qui va se retrouver dans le groupe de
l'argentine du mexique et de la pologne
puis qu'ils ne pouvaient pas tomber avec
l'iran
ça va être compliqué pour eux de marquer
des points oui ça va compliquer en même
temps j'ai envie de penser que derrière
l'argentine finalement c'est
relativement homogène tout cas le
mexique y est la pologne s'était pas les
équipes les plus fortes de leur chapeau
j'ai même envie de dire si un groupe
c'est un groupe qui est un petit peu en
dessous des autres ce sera peut-être le
groupe c
en tout cas c'est pas les plus grosses
équipes pour chaque chapeau
c'est presque une chance peut-être pour
l'arabie saoudite mais aussi pour le
mexique et la pole en tout cas ce tirage
au sort je pense que ouais ça peut ça
peut vraiment batailler dans ce groupe
alors que la deuxième équipe de playoffs
qui qui regroupe donc le pérou le costa
rica la nouvelle-zélande l'australie les
émirats arabes unis si j'ai bien les 5
va elle se retrouver dans un autre
groupe alors il faut voir contre qui il
peut jouer qui peut jouer je pense
qu'ils vont devrait se retrouver dans le
groupe e normalement et encore je ne
suis même pas sûr d'être dans le groupe
f alors cette voie là c'est bien dans le
groupe groupe e espagne allemagne japon
voilà bah c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour l'équipe qui va se qualifier pour
la coupe du monde parce que parce que ça
va se qualifier ça peut-être s'arrêter
là aussi donc ouais l'espagne l'espagne
à l'allemagne sauf si sauf fo sauf faute
professionnelle ces deux équipes seront
huitièmes de finale ça serait absolument
extraordinaire qu'on ait un barragiste
qui sortent une des ces deux équipes ou
même le japon
normalement la voix est plus ou moins
tracé dans ce groupe là sauf énorme
surprise mais évidemment quand même
surveiller ça parce que une croix ce que
forcément une coupe du monde ou
l'espagne ou l'allemagne sort en phase
de poules ça serait quelque chose
d'historique alors héloïse qui demande
la france pourrait tomber contre eux qui
ont 80 des cas on est en train de
vérifier alors il ya cinq équipes c'est
donc le pérou l'australie la
nouvelle-zélande le costa rica et les
émirats arabes unis qui pourront jouer
contre la france mais pour l'instant on
ne sait pas encore quelle laquelle de
ces équipes ce sera sera décidé en juin
alors qu'une équipe européenne par
contre qui va rejoindre l'angleterre
l'iran et les arts et les états unis
c'est l'équipe à choisir entre les
gosses ukraine et le pays de galles
ouais on en parle et on disait que
c'était peut-être la meilleure la
meilleure équipe du chapeau 4 se situait
peut-être réussir parce que le pays de
galles et l'ukraine on le rappelle si si
on avait vraiment respecté que le
classement lui le classement fifa et que
ses équipes étaient déjà qualifiées
elles ont arrêté dans le chapeau 2 le
pays de galles et l'ukraine en
l'occurrence par l'ecosse
donc oui l'équipe qui va se qualifier
par par ce barrage là va forcément un
petit peu titillé l'angleterre en phase
de poules et sera peut être
potentiellement favori à la
qualification en huitièmes de finale
avec l'angleterre alors j'ai la réponse
à la question de tout à l'heure sur qui
va affronter la france alors on va
enlever de l'équation la
nouvelle-zélande et le pérou et de
pardon excusez moi la nouvelle zélande
et le costa rica et autres a donc pérou
australie ou émirats arabes unis pour la
france france pérou par exemple ça nous
rappelle un peu des souvenirs ou france
australie france australie si je me dis
pas de bêtise et de était dans groupe en
2018 donc oui ça fera rappeler des bons
souvenirs globalement aux bleus quoi
qu'il arrive franchement c'est
potentiellement le ouais j'ai envie de
dire que c'était le plus abordable
possible dans le chapeau 4
c'est quand même des équipes qui ne sont
pas du tout habituée à performant coupe
du monde voire pas habituel a joué pour
les émirats arabes unis donc oui ce sera
largement à la portée de l'équipe de
france qui s'en sortent très très bien
sur ce tirage au sort le cameroun vient
d'être retirée le cameroun avec le
brésil la serbie et la suisse un groupe
aussi assez assez relevé finalement est
assez homogène derrière le brésil ouais
assez homogène ces moments parce que je
me demande si le brésil a pas aussi joué
le cameroun il n'ya pas très longtemps
au coude du
mgc soir 12 14 mai savard a rappelé
beaucoup de souvenirs pour le coup au
brésil maintenant oui c'est un groupe
très homogène derrière le brésil si tout
va bien le brésil va survoler ce groupe
là maintenant derrière ça fait beaucoup
bataillé parce que la serbie on les a
vus en éliminatoires ils sont quand même
été assez costaud je crois qu'ils ont
perdu aucun match au final ils ont fini
par envoyer le portugal en barrages la
suisse on les a vus à l'euro on l'a vu
que c'est une équipe qu'il fallait
absolument pas sous-estimer qu'ils
pouvaient tenir tête à de grosses
nations et le cameroun on a dit c'est
une équipe un peu en reconstruction qui
vient de changer de sélectionneur avec
rigobert song qui vient d'être nommé
donc c'est une équipe qui va se chercher
un petit peu qui va arriver bas chapeau
4 logique avec moins d'assurance moins
de garanties mais c'est quand même une
équipe qui a quelques bons joueurs dans
son équipe 4-1 c'était le score à la
coupe du monde 2014 cameroun cameroun
brésil donc le brésil 2 retrouve deux
anciens du groupe 2008 et à 2014
l'époque c'est le ghana qui s'est passé
ces deux gars là qui va te retirer
portugal uruguay corée et corée du sud
et ghana là encore ghana s'est pas
forcément très très bon tirage
non c'est pas vraiment un tirage cadeau
ça va rappeler peut-être des mauvais
souvenirs un peu au portugal qui avait
échoué le ghana en 2014 lorsqu'il avait
été sorti dès la phase de poule c'est
pas le ghana qui leur ai posé le plus de
problèmes sur cette phase de groupes
maintenant sur ce groupe 1 à cannes deux
équipes qui sortent un petit peu de judo
avec le portugal et l'uruguay sur le
papier signe de ces deux équipes ne
passe pas la phase de groupes et il ne
va pas en huitièmes de finale ce sera un
énorme échec effectivement et donc le
canada dernière équipe tirait va se
retrouver avec la belgique le maroc et
la croatie un groupe assez ouvert quand
même ce groupe là ouais assez ouverts
parce que le canada moi comme j'ai dit
je pense que ça peut être vraiment la
surprise ça peut être cet outsider qu'on
n'attend pas du tout qui est attendu en
coupe du monde qu'il n'a pas joué depuis
très très longtemps qui a quand même
déjà quelques bons joueurs et qui vise
une génération assez prometteuse pour la
coupe du monde 2026 qu'ils vont
organiser avec les états unis et le
mexique maintenant avec le maroc on m'a
dit que ces équipes qui cherchent
beaucoup qui a peu d'assurance qui a pas
mal discuté en interne la croatie un peu
difficile à jauger c'est plus la croatie
de 2018 qui avait fait une finale de
coupe du monde d'un autre côté on les
attendait pas en finale de coupe du
monde en 2018 donc on va forcément se
méfier maintenant la belgique il ya
rennes la belgique un peu les autres je
pense la belgique si tout va bien va
survoler le groupe là ils seront
visibles au final très bien alors
beaucoup beaucoup de questions alors on
va revenir sur ce sursaut sur ce tirage
au sort qui est maintenant qui est
maintenant terminée peut-être d'abord
bien évidemment parler du groupe de la
france france danemark tunisie plus le
barragiste donc pérou australie et
merlan venir on va aller on va finir par
l'apprendre par coeur je pense
on est sur un groupe pas mal pour la
polémique c'est
la france à peut-être le groupe le plus
facile des têtes de série la france
pourrait difficilement avoir un meilleur
tirage au sort
oui sur le sur le papier le danemark il
faudra forcément s'en méfier après ce
qu'on avait à l'euro c'est une équipe
très soudée très forte très sûre d'elle
très forte qui a vraiment une grande
force intérieure et on a vu que même
dans le jeu ça veut vraiment jouer qui
pouvaient poser beaucoup de problèmes à
beaucoup d'équipés et à de très grandes
nations donc il faudra forcément s'en
méfier maintenant pour le reste
normalement la france doit oui survolé
son groupe là franchement la france qui
fait neuf points sur ce groupe là c'est
largement vizada c'est presque ce qu'on
attend effectivement on attend du sol
après une qualification des ddd jamais
acquise on se rappelle les matches
contre le danemark par exemple qui sont
toujours compliquées en coupe du monde
pour l'équipe de france mais nan moi
comme comme vous l'avez dit c'est quand
même un groupe qui est abordable oui
largement abordable franchement la
france ne fait quasiment pas avoir un
meilleur tirage
certes danemark s'est pas non plus c'est
pas non plus une équipe cadeau donc il
faut forcément se méfier je pense
qu'elle est plus facile avec les états
unis avec le mexique
peut-être des retrouvailles avec la
suisse aurait pu être un petit peu un
petit peu amusante et je pense que la
france serait revenue avec avec plus
d'assurance plus de force et ex temps a
été plus une mauvaise nouvelle pour pour
la suisse que pour la france maintenant
le danemark c'est une équipe que la
france peut largement dominé et pour le
reste du groupe normalement les autres
équipes dont je n'aime pas faire
illusion contre les bleus si jamais les
bleus jouent à leur vrai niveau
physiquement alors on va vous rappeler
donc les premiers matches je vois que
c'est assez incroyable la page de
wikipedia de la coupe du monde a déjà
été mis à jour toujours toujours aussi
rapide donc dans le groupe d l'équipe de
france va rabat
va jouer le 22 novembre son premier
match contre cette équipe donc soit le
pérou soit le l'australie soit les
émirats arabes unis ça sera décidé en
juin pas avant ensuite un deuxième match
qu'elle jouera contre le danemark le 26
novembre le 26 novembre et le 30
novembre on aura un match évidemment
contre la tunisie quatrième équipe de ce
groupe on pense quand même ce groupe il
n'est pas si homogène il ya vraiment
quatre équipes qui vont être chacune
enfin on voit vraiment que le danemark
est la deuxième meilleure équipe et la
tunisie quoique la tunisie peut être
aussi forte que le pérou finalement oui
sur un malentendu on verra normalement
le danemark doit sortir de ce groupe là
en tout cas le danemark va arriver avec
cette ambition clairement quand on voit
le tirage au sort on l'a dit la tunisie
c'est l'une des six n'est l'équipe la
moins forte de chapeau 3 c'est pas une
équipe qui a été impressionnante en can
c'est inutile qui a lu quelques quelques
difficultés aussi en barrage donc c'est
pas c'est pas une équipe cadets star
c'est pas c'est pas une équipe ce qu'on
attend franchement en coupe du monde
maintenant elle est là elle est quand
même assez habitués à connaît les
grandes compétitions après m'impose
cette expérience ce vécu mais
franchement ça s'arrête là je pense pour
l'équipe de france en allemand ça doit
pas ne pas y avoir vraiment de match il
ya toujours des matchs forcément en
coupe du monde ça peut jamais être
facile mais normand pour l'équipe de
france doit pas y avoir photo et même
pour le danemark le danemark va arriver
avec beaucoup plus de certitudes
beaucoup plus de vécu plus de talent
aussi tout simplement
normalement le classement du groupe il
est déjà plus ou moins établie sur le
papier dites nous dans les commentaires
ce qui vous pensez que le que l'équipe
de france va remporter sont facilement
en une question du maroc alors on va
débriefer bien évidemment tous les
groupes le maroc peut-il se sortir de ce
groupe belgique canada maroc croatie
alors on parle du groupe de la mort avec
le groupe e qui avec les deux autres qui
ont été tirés ont été moins
impressionnant
sarsat ça ressemble aussi quand même un
jeu avec la croatie le canada le rappel
dans le chapeau 4 c'était aussi l'une
des meilleures équipes oui l'une des
meilleures équipes parce que c'est une
équipe qui a largement dominé son groupe
de la phase éliminatoire
c'est une équipe or c'est à ce qu'on
connaît pas donc on va pas non plus
faire de grandes déclarations sur sur
canada mais il a quand même quelques
jours qu'on connaît notamment jonathan
davies qui est quand même le fer de
lance de cette équipe et qui tombe
plutôt bien à lille
donc oui c'est une équipe dont il faudra
vraiment se méfier je pense que ça a
tout du match piège tout de l'outsider
qu'on n'attend pas et qui peut créer la
surprise pour le maroc c'est vraiment
pas cadeau il va falloir je pense
vraiment accéléré sur les sur les
prochains rendez vous pour le maroc
parce que c'est une équipe qui arrive
avec trop peu de certitudes qui a trop
déçue elle a qu'un pour vraiment dire on
va prétendre à un huitième de finale de
coupe du monde surtout dans ce groupe là
où sur le papier moi je pense qu'il ya
pas photo entre la avec la belgique la
croatie il ya deux équipes qui sont
vraiment au dessus du lot ça va être un
groupe difficile pour pour le maroc on
attend d'abord eu de commentaires sur le
sur le groupe b l'angleterre iran etats
unis plus l'équipe européenne novedia lé
pays de galles ukraine écosse dans ce
groupe c le groupe qui a priori alors le
facile et heureusement que c'est une
équipe européenne finalement on parler
d'eux avant le avant le début ce tirage
de ce fait que cette équipe européenne
avait un meilleur classement fifa aurait
pu se retrouver dans le chapeau 2 se
retrouve finalement dans le chapeau 4 on
peut dire que grâce à ça on est revenue
un peu au point de dessin a été
rééquilibré peut-être finalement parce
que après on verra évidemment quelle
équipe va sortir que les parages parce
que effectivement un pays de galles ou
l'ukraine s'il avait été déjà qualifiés
d'office ils ont été dans le chapeau 2
donc forcément ça aurait changé les
choses maintenant on peut se demander si
jamais le pays de galles et l'ukraine si
l'un des douze qualifiés
est-ce que c'est pas en fait la deuxième
meilleure équipe de ce groupe là devant
les états unis
parce que les états unis ils ont eu
beaucoup de mal en barrages qui sont
passés à la dernière journée ils ont ils
ont un petit peu transpirer ils ont pas
ils n'ont pas un groupe très très
expérimentés ils ont groupe assez jeune
vraiment leur objectif c'est très
clairement la coupe du monde 2026 qui
vont co-organiser avec le mexique et le
canada donc c'est plus leur rendez vous
franchement on les entend pas beaucoup
je pense que si jamais le pays de galles
se qualifiant les scindera un peu plus
et même l'ukraine une crainte c est qu
il compte actuellement pas jugé
aujourd'hui
qui a montré quand même de bonnes choses
sur sa phase éliminatoire qui a été
accrocheuse donc il faudra forcément
s'en méfier mais évidemment tout un
contexte social et humain qu'il faudra
prendre en compte au moment de la coupe
du monde alors je suis en train de vous
lire vos commentaires en même temps
c'est un tirage au sort aussi pour les
huitièmes de finale non les huitièmes de
finale sont déjà décidées les groupes à
se croiser avec les groupes b groupe c
avec groupe des groupes e et f et objets
avec groupe h par exemple le premier du
groupe à brailler groupe à on a un
groupe quand même assez ouvert
assez ouvert avait enfin plutôt vous
dira on peut quand même dire que les
deux huitièmes groupe à groupe b ont pas
être non plus incroyables à priori oui a
priori c'est pas c'est vrai les deux
groupes qui font qu'ils font rêver
surtout d'un groupe à même les pays-bas
alors certes c'est une des meilleures
équipes je pense du chapeau 2 mais c'est
une équipe qui a plus beaucoup de
certitudes sur les dernières
compétitions internationales il en a
manqué quelques unes notamment l'euro
2016 et la coupe du monde 2018 aussi si
je dis pas de bêtises donc c'est pas
c'est une équipe là aussi qu'on attend
un petit peu au tournant donc il ya des
joueurs assez jeune mathias de l'irt
frais qui donne donc on a parlé tout à
l'heure certains de ces leaders qui ont
quand une expérience assez relative en
tout cas sur de tels de telles
compétitions
maintenant derrière oui c'est assez
sereine assez homogène le sénégal qui
peut largement faire un coup c'est même
peut-être dans les favoris de ce conte
plat pour se qualifier en huitièmes et
derrière les locataires l'équateur sur
un malentendu ils peuvent peut-être
créer une surprise sénégal premier de
groupe qu'ils rencontrent au pays de
galles qui s'est qualifiée il ya des
barrages en 8èmes c'est qu'on peut être
possible voilà c'est tout à fait
possible c'est pas un huitième de finale
extraordinaire on a quelques uns qui
peuvent être beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
impressionnant je pense notamment à
l'espagne et l'allemagne l'un de ces
deux pays qui pourrait jouer par exemple
la croatie ou peut-être même la belgique
n'a forcément ça serait pas le même
niveau de huitièmes de finale salle
offrir un joli choc le groupe c on peut
parler du groupe c'est l'argentine qui a
l'air favori de l'arabie saoudite bien
en dessous et mexique pologne en
embuscade pour cette deuxième place qui
en plus va jouer en équipe de france en
8e oui c'est ça aussi qu'on va qu'on va
pas forcément pas mal surveillées dans
ce groupe c et
veut pas trop s'avancer évidemment
faudra jouer les matches mais sauf
catastrophe industrielle l'équipe de
france sera en huitièmes de finale et
défendra son titre à ce moment là
maintenant sur sur le groupe c oui à
l'argentine devant il ya l'air habits
saoudite normalement sur le papier deux
dernières de ce groupe là en tout cas
quatrième équipe entre missika la
pologne pas deux équipes qui prétendent
à grand grand chose qui avec une grande
ambition dans cette coupe du monde le
mexique là aussi qu'on attendait plus un
petit peu au tournant en 2026 quand ils
accueilleront quelques matchs de la
coupe du monde et la pologne on a dit
c'est décevant globalement ils sont ils
ont été il se retrouver dans le chapeau
3 mais pas très haut dans le chapeau 3
donc c'est dire c'est pas une équipe qui
arrive avec une grande force collective
effectivement donc le groupe dès l'aube
de la forme on a pas mal parlé le groupe
e espagne allemagne costa rica japon
espagne allemagne alors c'est un peu
compliqué pour costa rica nouvelle
zélande selon celui qui sera là et le
japon on s'est compliqué pour les
huitièmes oui je pense que c'est
peut-être le groupe on a le plus deux
équipes au dessus et deux équipes en
dessous parce que le costa rica et la
nouvelle-zélande quoi qu'il arrive ce ne
sont pas les équipes qui arrivent avec
une grande ambition fut un temps le
costa rica était un petit peu l'équipe
dont il fallait se méfier notamment la
coupe du monde 2014 si je me dis pas si
t'es pas de bêtises ils font quarts de
finale je crois qu'il tombe sur le
brésil
je crois que c'est aux tirs aux buts on
est forcément il faut il faudra un petit
peu s'en méfier maintenant le japon
c'est cette équipe un peu un petit peu
pâle à gratter mais qu'ils fassent
jamais faire grand chose au final fin
2018 contre la belgique la belgique les
bas 3 2 dans le temps additionnel à 94
yens sur un but de darche a dit c'était
voilà c'est pas une équipe facile à
jouer c'est ça c'est pas une équipe
facile à jouer maintenant je sais pas
quand ça remonte à la fois qu'ils ont
fait ne serait qu'un quart de finale de
coupe du monde 6 ans ont déjà fait
normalement pour l'espagne et
l'allemagne souhaitant pas poser
problème en tout cas au stade de la
phase de poules alors on nous dit groupe
d groupe g ça ressemble quand même
beaucoup à 2018 effectivement le
danemark était était déjà là pérou
australie s'il y en a deux ils étaient
déjà là aussi et le groupe g brésil
serbie suisse il était aussi déjà en 8
bits et le cameroun était là et elle en
2014 effectivement
on a joué contre qui je suis je de jolis
vos messages il y en a effectivement
beaucoup à j'essaye de seuil de répondre
à toutes vos questions on m'a parlé du
groupe f du coup maintenant belgique
croatie marocain l'ordre a peu parlé
sous le prisme du maroc la belgique a un
vrai coup à faire dans ce dans ce groupe
même s'ils arrivent en ville ça va être
ça va être compliqué mais belgique
croatie là aussi le canada peut jouer la
surprise mais belgique croatie son cabas
c'est au dessus ils sont entendus en
huitièmes de finale je pense ils sont
clairement entendu sur papier ces deux
équipes qui sort du lot on l'a dit le
maroc le maroc trop de trop de manque de
garanties d'assurance de deux de vécu
collectif même on sent que c'est un
groupe qui se remet un type en question
en tout cas vahid halilhozic beaucoup
contesté qui est qui a lui aussi qu on
sent qu'ils tâtonnent un petit peu
qu'ils se posent beaucoup de questions
avec le fameux fantôme d'acquisition de
suzuki n'est plus sélectionné pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils ne devraient pas être
rappelé tout ça donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué pour eux le canada normalement
on les attend pas on l'a 10 ont fait une
grosse phase éliminatoire ils ont un peu
ce côté outsiders qu'on n'attend pas du
tout et qui va créer la surprise donc je
pense que la belgique et la croatie
devant ce métier n'est normalement si
tout va bien on aura la belgique est la
croatie en huitièmes de finale on à
arnaud qui nous demande on va jouer
contre qui la france on va jouer contre
le danemark la tunisie c'est sûr et
ensuite une quatrième équipe parmi pérou
australie émirats arabes unis ce sera a
décidé lors de
barrages on s'imagine que les émirats
arabes unis sous la peau l'équipe la
moins forte de sparages et ça serait
quand même plutôt se jouer entre le père
ou l'australie oui en théorie on peut
penser parce que les émirats arabes unis
ça fait très très longtemps je passe ils
ont déjà fait une confusion de 21e
siècle donc c'est pas du tout une équipe
à laquelle on s'attendrait à voir ici
maintenant oui l'australie c'est un
habitué quand même c'est un habitué mais
c'est pas une équipe qui fait grand
chose non plus dans cette compétition
d'un petit peu comme le perron
dans tous les cas ce sera une équipe
d'un niveau assez assez relatif à
l'italie claudine lacroix 6 nuls modric
est devenu trop vieux et même c'est plus
la même équipe alors la croatie est
moins bonne qu'en 2018 modric et être
plus vieux mais on l'a vu contre le psg
en 8e de finale avec le real madrid il
l'a pas encore nous avons perdu et puis
ils ont quand même une belle génération
qui arrive ils ont ils ils ont des
tauliers que nous avons encore d'après
de bronze au 800 r c'est encore une
équipe qui compte en europe oui bien sûr
et puis c'est une équipe qui se
renouvelle toujours qu'aujourd'hui 4ème
un statut qui est vraiment implémenté
dans le plutôt dans le haut panier assez
globale du football européen même sur le
cadre de reach pense qu'il faut pas trop
s'emballer alors ça sera un contexte un
petit peu compliqué parce que je crois
qu'il a toujours pas prolongé au real
madrid puisqu'il sera encore au real
madrid et aussi ce sera une coupe du
monde encore une fois en milieu de
saison ça je pense qu'on va en parler
pas mal tout au long de l'été et tout au
long de du début de saison prochain pour
certains jours ça va être plus compliqué
à aborder un joueur comme luka modric
qui a peut-être plus de mal à enchaîner
les matches qui peut encore performer
sur des séquences est ce qu'il pourra
être encore le taulier de cette croatie
à ce moment là est ce que vous faites là
croatie m'a vraiment compter sur lui ça
j'en suis pas sûr mais c'est quand même
une équipe qu'on peut absolument pas
prendre à la légère effectivement la
croatie finalistes de daegu beaucoup de
monde ils ne sont pas arrivés ici par
hasard
on va on va peut-être du groupe j'ai
donc on va dire waouh groupe ac qui
ressemble beaucoup au beaucoup beaucoup
dernier pareil brésil suisse c'est quand
même au dessus même si srbica monde ça
va ça va être compliqué pour la suisse
oui ça va être assez assez compliqué la
suisse qui est un peu difficile à jauger
parce que c'est une équipe en fait assez
irrégulière dans ses performances en
compétition si on reste sur l'euro
doit être sur le papier clairement le
deuxième de ce groupe là parce qu'on l'a
vu contre l'équipe de france mais même
contre l'espagne qui une équipe qui a
vraiment posé beaucoup de problèmes très
solide très assez assez décomplexée
finalement qui sait peut-être aussi
décomplexée à travers cet euro donc il
faudra vraiment se méfier
maintenant la serbie qu'elle mettait
aussi assez assez fort en phase de
groupes dans un groupe avec le portugal
ils ont vraiment tenu bon ils ont une
vraie force de caractère il avait
cherché la qualif la dernière minute le
cameroun j'ai envie dire que c'est un
petit cran en dessous parce que c'est
une équipe en construction ils viennent
de changer de sélectionneur qu'ils ont
nommée ils ont le mérite commerçants n'y
a même pas un mois donc c'est une équipe
qui va se reconstruire qui n'arrive pas
pour performer en coupe du monde qui va
plutôt se reconstruire pour recréer un
groupe créé une équipe solide sur les
prochaines années on à charlie qu'ils
demandent c'est qui le 4 ème du groupe
gib a du coup tu parles de la france le
quatrième du groupe c'est une équipe à
choisir entre le pérou l'australie et
les émirats arabes unis ce sera décidé
en juin à voilà merci sacha dans les
commentaires il y aurait de répondre
aussi à cet internaute un groupe e en
2018 donc brésil suisse serbie costa
rica c'est la suisse et qui étaient
sortis de ce groupe la suisse qui avait
d'ailleurs match nul contre le brésil ou
en ouverture puis qui avait battu la
suisse avait battu la serbie et le
brésil aussi a battu la serbie je crois
me souvenir que la suisse avait aussi
battu l'espagne beaucoup de monde 2006
son premier match de l'espagne et c'est
une équipe souvent qui est vraiment
pénible à jouer et qui peut vraiment
jouer des mauvais coups qui a ses
habitués à ça effectivement pas et du
dernier groupe le dernier groupe
portugal ghana uruguay le portugal
semble semble au dessus voilà évacuer le
monde et le groupe h le groupage on en
parle portugal ghana uruguay portugal a
l'air au-dessus ghana uruguay corée du
sud ça va ça va se battre pour le pour
la 2e place oui ça va un petit peu se
battre normalement l'uruguay et part
favori sur le papier crème assez assez
assez clairement maintenant on en a
parlé tout à l'heure de l'uruguay c'est
une équipe un peu vieillissante avec
cadres vieillissants pense être des
gogos dean acheson cavani et luis suarez
même si pour cavani suarez il ya
notamment la relève darwin nunez en
attaque
donc c'est une équipe qui doit qu'ils
ont un petit peu ce se retrouver se
reconstruire café que un quart de finale
en copa america c'est quand même assez
décevant pour pour elle c'est quand même
une équipe qu'on attend normalement sur
le papier deuxième de ce groupe là
maintenant le ghana la corée du sud ces
deux équipes à ses habitués le ghana qui
est quand même un petit peu dans le jour
aujourd'hui qui n'a plus la génération
brillante de 2010 qui avaient réussi à
accrocher un quart de finale qui avait
d'ailleurs beaucoup embêté l'uruguay ça
va faire un petit à petit flashback avec
un match chaud pour pour luis suarez
notamment cela lui rappelait je pense
des souvenirs petit uruguay-ghana ça
appelle ça rappelle de beaux souvenirs
avec avec luis suarez on rappelle qu'ils
avaient pas jouer gardien de but mais ta
loi oui car vous allez qui avait
clairement je veux gardien de but
l'espace d'une seconde et et la corée du
sud c'est le vrai habitués de cette
coupe du monde quasiment toujours
qualifiés qui fait rarement grand chose
sauf air évidemment l'exploit de 2002 de
faire une demi finale à domicile
maintenant c'est là aussi les équipes un
petit peu un petit peu comme comme
d'autres comme comme les états unis
comme comme le japon ce genre d'équipé
qui est un peu toujours là comme le
mexique ou même potentiellement
australie qui est toujours là et qu'il
faut quand même réussir à manoeuvrer
réussir à passer maintenant par rapport
à ces trois équipes là il ya quand même
une équipe normalement qui au dessus du
lot sur papier c'est pour tuer oui on
rappelle le uruguay-ghana c'était en
2010 quart de finale de la coupe du
monde l'uruguay
le ghana à la dernière minute je crois
il ya une tête dans le but ces soirées
ce qu'ils arrêtent à la main
complètement tel un gardien de but il
prend un carton rouge le l'attaquant
ghanéen rate le penalty et derrière
c'est l'uruguay qui gagne aux tirs au
but c'était pas très bon pour le sport
mais bon au sahara sahel
c'est un peu à l'image de jeu suarez et
je pense que je pense que le ghana lors
a toujours un petit peu en travers de la
gorge il y aura pour vie peut-être de
prendre de prendre cette revanche années
70 rappelez-vous face à suarez le
tricheur peut peut-être en parler on à
infiniti qg de la pointe il ses chansons
rap zen qui nous reparle de l'allemagne
ne va pas reparler un peu de ce groupe
espagne-allemagne clairement devant dans
ce groupe le japon ça km très compliqué
pour pouvoir arriver à faire quelque
chose oui ça va être compliqué parce que
l'espagne on se demande si ça fait
partie de ce 1er août favori en tout cas
je pense que on peut voir monde pensé et
l'argumenter c'est tout à fait possible
parce que c'est une équipe qui a des
joueurs de top niveau à toutes les
lignes qui connaît son football qui a
fait grosse impression à l'euro
c'est vraiment une équipe qui peut
vraiment qui peut vraiment dominé cette
coupe du monde mais qui peut aller très
très loin et l'allemagne sûrement la
meilleure équipe du chapeau 2 donc donc
oui pour le japon pour une équipe comme
le japon alors le chapeau 4
c'est une équipe à priori un petit peu
de moindre calibre maintenant sur les
deux premiers chapeau c'est pas loin
d'être le pire tirage possible pour le
japon effectivement c'était vraiment ça
va être intéressant qui va être assez
compliqué fatima qui nous demande de
parler du sénégal du groupe à le groupe
à on l'a dit le sénégal qui en est très
très bien tirés lors de ce 2 de ce
tirage au sort avec finalement un groupe
avec l'équateur et le qatar qui devrait
leur permettre d'arriver en huitièmes
oui bah tout le monde voulait le qatar
comme équipe du chapeau 1 ça c'était
clair clair et évident c'est le sénégal
dans le chapeau 3 qui en héritent donc
ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle en
tout cas sur le papier même si encore
une fois on l'a dit le qatar à domicile
il faut toujours se méfier d'une équipe
à domicile on l'a vu avec la russie en
2018 d'ailleurs qui avait été quart de
finaliste
maintenant pour le reste les pays bas
partent clairement favoris mais là aussi
assez faible expérience sur la
compétence sur les compétitions
internationales sur les dernières
compétitions
vraiment ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
repères va beaucoup de références donc
il faudra peut-être se reconstruit un
petit peu là dessus il arrive crème avec
beaucoup moins de garanties et je pense
que l'allemagne en l'occurrence qui
était aussi dans le chapeau 2 maintenant
sur l'équateur enfin c'est quand même
une équipe assez abordable en tout cas
sur sur chapola sur le chapeau 4
resté un peu l'équipe un petit peu
middle
pour le sénégal normalement c'est une
équipe le sénégal peut largement
prétendre à dominer le qatar et
l'équateur pour aller en huitièmes de
finale je pense qu'on va pas tarder
arrêté là puisqu'il y
avait encore des blagues sur l'algérie
qui reviennent val qui dit vous forçait
que les bacs sur l'algérie je suis
d'accord avec toi sauf que je suis
d'accord avec toi
ilan qui nous demandent la pologne at
elle ses chances oui dans le groupe c le
groupe c était quand même assez ouvert
même la pologne face au mexique a comme
un petit avantage et devrait être cette
deuxième équipe qui pourrait affronter
la france en huitièmes oui peuvent tout
à fait là ça peut tout à fait être
l'équipe le prochain adversaire des
bleus après après la phase de groupe si
tout va bien pour l'équipe de france
évidemment maintenant oui entre la
pologne et le mexique mais s'il n'y a
pas non plus une génération incroyable
qui arrive pas avec de grandes ambitions
qui arrive pas en outsider vraiment
effrayant
maintenant la pologne qui n'a pas non
plus engrangé 4 avons marqué deux points
je dirais en tout cas ni collectivement
et individuellement sur ces sur ses deux
derniers rendez vous déjà en barrages
ils ont été qualifiés on rappelle que
ils n'ont pas eu à affronter la russie
puisque la russie a été disqualifié par
la fifa et que derrière ils ont réussi à
dominer la suède dans un match quand
même assez peu emballant ou la pologne a
largement dominé les débats
parler ce que la pologne est le deuxième
ou troisième du groupe sur le papier
franchement c'est très difficile à dire
mais en tout cas c'est une équipe
normalement qui va ambitionner de jouer
les huitièmes de finale et donc
potentiellement d'affronter la france ça
parle de groupe de la mort dans les
commentaires le groupe d'abord alors on
nous dit que c'est quand même le groupe
g effectivement ce groupe c au groupe
brésil serbie suisse cameroun est assez
impressionnant mais j'ai pas avant qu'il
ya un vrai groupe de la mort dans cette
coupe du monde
c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même deux
équipes d'un niveau exceptionnel d'un
groupe e qui peut vraiment pas être
prétendre à la victoire finale avec
l'espagne et l'allemagne maintenant
derrière c'est déjà nettement plus
faible et effectivement le groupe g en
fait c'était un des groupes les plus
homogènes voilà je pense le complexe
aussi quand même les halles c est quand
même d'un niveau assez papa pas si
mauvais
ouais peut-être les groupes les plus
serrées à la fois les plus relevés ouais
peut-être le groupe f le groupe g en
tout cas c'est là que c'est un peu ça
peut être assez tendue et qu'il y aura
vraiment des frais des suspenses très
simple qui nous dit vous avez pas eu les
droits pour diffuser le terrain en
direct et bien non nous n'avions pas le
droit mais vous avez pu vivre avec nous
ce tirage qui sait que c'est comme ça
qui est important ce n'est aucunement
est ce que le maroc a ses chances on
vous l'a dit le maroc qui se retrouve
face à la belgique et la croatie ça
danse ça compliqué par an on peut quand
même dire que groupe des groupes b ça a
l'air d'être les groupes les plus
simples ont une fois de plus alors à
part ce petit accroc au dernier euro on
peut dire que desliers deschamps
continue à avoir un peu de chance aussi
rage oui oui s'en sort et s'en sortent
toujours bien il a toujours un peu son
porte bonheur avec les visiblement donc
oui la france la france s'en sort bien
et là aussi pour le coup l'angleterre
qui a un tirage quand même assez assez
clément alors on nous demande quand
est-ce que ça quand est-ce qu'ils auront
lieu les matchs donc le 22 novembre la
france affrontera le pérou les émirats
arabes unis où la l'australie excusez
moi ce sera donc le 22 novembre le 26
ils joueront contre le danemark et le 30
ils joueront contre la tunisie
effectivement le rappelle une coupe du
monde qui se déroule en hiver quelque
chose qui va et kate qui est assez
spécial pour dans une dans une coupe du
monde est ce que vous pensez que l'iran
a des chances de se qualifier l'iran
finalement ils ont la chance de se
retrouver dans un
groupe assez ouvert ça va dépendre
qu'elle est quand même l'équipe
européenne qui les rejoint oui
finalement on a envie de dire que le
lire on s'en sort pas trop mal en tout
cas sur sur son tirage au sort
maintenant effectivement ça va dépendre
de l'équipe européenne en principe sur
le papier une envie de penser qu'au pays
de galles et l'ukraine arrive plus fort
que l'ecosse même si évidemment
l'ukraine il y aura tout ce contexte
assez particulier à prendre en compte
est ce que ça pour aller permettre de de
surperformer ou est ce que c'est une
équipe qui va arriver dans une situation
catastrophique c'est absolument rien
aujourd'hui maintenant pays de galles
aussi à l'air quand même d'avoir d'avoir
ce petit truc en plus en coupe du monde
ou en euros on l'a vu avec gareth bale
dans des barrages qui qui s'est un peu
un peu réveillé parce qu'il vit une
saison encore très difficile
ouais ça va ça va quand même être assez
difficile pour l'iran face à cette
équipe européenne et les etats unis qui
normalement doivent un minimum assumer
leur statut à quatre ans de leur coupe
du monde entre guillemets on abat un
manque évident et on est d'accord que
sont les deux premiers de groupe qui
sont qualifiés bien évidemment ce sont
les deux premiers pour ce format c'est
la dernière fois que la coupe du monde a
lieu sur ce fort ce format ça changera à
la prochaine je crois que j'ai pris à
peu près toutes les questions vous aviez
merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir été
avec nous très nombreux à suivre ce
tirage au sort et on vous donne rendez
vous coût pour la coupe du monde bien
évidemment qui se déroulera je reprends
mais là tu
cesseras le dise ça commence le 18 ou le
21 voix le 21 novembre ça commencé le 18
décembre ça se termine une coupe du
monde qui a lieu en hiver merci à vous
d'avoir été très nombreux à nous suivre
avoir posé des questions je remercie une
nouvelle fois ryad à la réalisation
sacha qui était qui était à la
modération du tchat et vous étiez très
nombreux donc merci elle est bien
évidemment à sébastien pour nous avoir
offert tout son analyse sur c'est
sur ce tirage au sort voilà jean
bafouille merci en tout cas une nouvelle
fois à vous de voir suivi et moi je vous
dis à bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
fear alive